[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us
epic was founded on building great games
and sharing all of our technology openly
with the community we succeed when you
succeed and we want all developers to
have the advantages we have ourselves
when building games like fortnite unreal
engine 5 is the latest chapter
we released the early access preview
back in may and the community has built
some amazing things in it let's take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today we're launching unreal engine 5.0
to all developers it's been battle
tested in fortnite chapter 3 launched
last december so download it today and
get started
what's most exciting now is that real
time 3d is bringing industries together
with honorable engine 5 as their common
medium
among game developers 48 of announced
next generation console titles are
powered by unreal automotive designers
fashion designers and architects are
doing everything from design
visualization to brand activations and
entertainment crossovers film and
television producers are using unreal
for virtual production on set and for
final pixels on the movie screen then
they're bringing their content to games
and live events on a mass scale
we're seeing the emergence of a new
medium connecting people around the
world live and shared experiences
wherever you build today is a stepping
stone to bigger things in the future so
come join us on the journey and we'll
build this future together
next up i'd like to introduce kim le
berry cto of epic games
hello everybody
i can't believe it's been eight years
since we shipped unreal engine four
and seven years since we made it free
for everybody's use
since then we've seen huge growth in
engine usage spanning games as well as
many other industries
this incredible journey has afforded us
the opportunity to work with some of the
best creators from all over the planet
it's the work which has driven us to
keep pushing the envelope to the point
where we are today which is the release
of unreal engine 5. one of the founding
principles of the company is that we
bring the lessons we learn from our own
game development back into unreal
the scale and success of fortnite took
that model to a whole new level putting
all that work back into the engine has
made unreal engine way better across all
platforms
i joined epic because i've always
believed that real-time technology has
the power to revolutionize the creative
process across all industries
being able to make instantaneous
decisions within a near photoreal
interactive environment is utterly
transformative
it empowers you to make big changes to a
scene and see them immediately in
context
this is a better quicker and much more
efficient way of creating content it's
been fantastic to see our customers
using the engine in so many different
ways from indie creative projects all
the way up to aaa games and even movies
but for us to really be sure that unreal
engine 5 has achieved the goals we set
for it to really change the way
interactive and linear media is made
we needed to push the engine to a new
extreme
and that's how the matrix awakens demo
came about
how do we know what is real
i was fortunate enough to have worked on
the first three matrix movies at a time
when visual effects was revolutionizing
the movie business
having the opportunity to work on
another matrix project and push
technology yet again was really special
it was a privilege for us to bring the
matrix universe to a whole new
generation of viewers and players we
wanted to show that high-end visuals at
a massive scale were possible in a
living breathing and believable open
world and we wanted to show that a
player could be immersed in an exciting
cinematic scene that would normally only
be possible in a blockbuster film
what's been fantastic is seeing how a
fully interactive set can change the
process of filmmaking
in what can be described as life
imitating art we actually filmed the
cinematic sections of the demo inside
the matrix city we had built
where our artists would drive cars
set up stunts and place pyrotechnics all
inside a fully simulated world
and because this is a simulation that
can be recorded by unreal we can then
place optimal cameras in the scene after
the fact to give maximum cinematic
impact
unreal engine 5 isn't just about making
existing ways of doing things faster
it's about finding whole new approaches
to transform the way content is made and
experienced
micro polygon geometry allows for
billions of triangles on the screen at
any moment
and luma's real-time global illumination
enables highly realistic lighting they
combine together to generate real-time
content at a level that would have
seemed like magic only a few years ago
for the building of the matrix megacity
we didn't have a huge environment team
so we had to build it in a really smart
and efficient way
we wanted to create a large-scale city
with fidelity and complexity beyond what
is typical in an open world game and for
this we deployed procedural content
creation techniques including partnering
with our friends at side effects to use
houdini and houdini engine
developer efficiency is a recurring
theme that goes beyond unreal engine and
into our other products
meta human creator and quicksort maker
scans show how we're enabling creators
to make very high quality content more
quickly than ever before
pulling together the city for the matrix
awakens and bringing it to life would
have been impossible without these tools
unreal engine is revolutionizing how
creators tell stories and how people
experience them
enabling developers to leverage one set
of assets for whatever type of content
they can dream up from games to linear
animation and even to live-action shows
and movies
one of the most important aspects of
creating the matrix awakens demo was our
commitment to release the city as a
sample content
we want to show in a step-by-step manner
how we created this world together and
to provide a starting point for others
to make their own worlds tell stories
even build new games on top of this
incredible digital city
unreal engine 5 is the foundation of
next-gen content creation so what are
you waiting for go make something
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
starting today it's never been easier to
bring your creative vision to life
we built ue5 by looking at each
individual aspect and asking ourselves
what technical hurdles can we remove to
help developers put creativity first we
redesigned the unreal editor ui making
it easier to use with a streamlined
modern look keeping you inside the 3d
world that you're building and we built
tools for animation and modeling
directly into the editor enabling
developers to fine-tune and iterate on
content in context without round trips
to external packages
lumen frees developers to create dynamic
worlds with high quality global
illumination
nanite relieves developers from worrying
about draw call polygon and memory
budgets from a geometry perspective
and our new open world tools allow
developers to collaborate in a single
massive level
and to get you building even faster
alongside ue5 we're shipping lyra a new
starter game it's a complete end-to-end
networked multiplayer game project that
is an excellent foundation to build a
game upon without having to start from a
blank slate
it's built for modular components
utilizes epic online services for
matchmaking and is designed to run on pc
console and mobile with lyra you can
jump in customize it add new content and
begin play testing from day one to see
how easy it is to build on top of lyra
let's jump in the editor with zach
parrish
okay so here we are inside of the unreal
editor and this is the lyra project and
this is the expanse level one of three
different levels that ship with the lyra
project and i'm just gonna jump right in
and play the game so i'll click the play
button and boom we're we're playing lyra
inside the editor and i know there's a
bot waiting for me up here and he's
gonna try to get the shotgun and i can't
let that happen because it won't go well
for me come on i can do this
okay well
saw that coming it's probably going to
happen a lot throughout this demo now
what we're going to be focusing on is
how we can take this level and modify it
and really start to make lyra our own
but before we do that i want to call out
the lighting this level is lit primarily
with just the sunlight as a matter of
fact if i move the sun around
you can see how lumen just takes that
light and naturally bounces it around
the scene and the light is influenced by
the surfaces it hits so if i was to take
the floor for example and just drag and
drop a new material on it like like red
for example you can now see there's red
light bouncing around the scene and if
you really just want to
crank it up to 11 i could drag and drop
like this neon green color that i
imported from the early 90s and you can
see that the sunlight hits that and
floods the whole scene with green light
now i would never leave it that way
because that looks awful
now in addition to bounce light lumen
also allows us to illuminate our scenes
using emissive materials so here's a
ball that has an emissive material on it
and it is casting light into the scene
but it's hard to see with all this
sunlight so let's just take the sun and
tuck it up underneath the level and now
you can see that the ball actually is
casting light and there is no light
actor there this is all happening by way
of the material thanks to lumen in fact
if i take the material and change its
color we can change the color of the
light and if i increase that emissive
value we can actually flood the scene
with more light and
in the process make a sphere that's
actually painful to look at
now that light is dynamic you can see as
i move the ball around
that lighting is following along
so let's take a look at modifying our
level i'll just tuck the ball up here
into the corner and let's bring the sun
back now lyra was designed from the
ground up for you to build your own
games on and to help with that we've
created a series of tools to help you
out
so this looks like a regular static mesh
of a window that i just duplicated off
the back wall but actually this is a
procedural mesh so if i get it into the
middle of the room
and then right click on it and go to
scripted actor actions i can swap this
out to its generated mesh and now we can
see a selection of handles that i can
move around and you see how that updates
the object so i can move the window
around inside the shape and if i go over
to the details panel i can increase the
wall's width we could increase its
height
we could actually adjust you know what
let's take the opening and we'll change
it to make this into like a bunker that
i can kind of hide behind to give me
some protection from these bots so we'll
make that narrow we'll slide it down a
little bit
maybe i'll increase the width by just a
little and when i'm done i just need to
convert this into a regular static mesh
i'll do that by clicking generate new
static mesh and then right click
and choose swap to static mesh and boom
this is a mesh just like any other that
you'd use to build a level now of course
we're not limited to just duplicating
existing meshes if i wanted to i can
bring in fresh ones from the tools menu
that's included in the lyra install and
you'll find that this is full of a
series of these procedural tools that
are all built using blueprint on top of
the already existing modeling tools in
the unreal editor so i can bring in this
panel and just move this handle around
to quickly drag out a ceiling for our
little bunker and if i'm happy with that
just right click
and swap that over to a static mesh i do
need a way to get up here which i'll
admit the whole thing was just an excuse
for me to show you this really cool
procedural stairway so if i drag this in
check it out i'm going to rotate it
around and aim it where it needs to go
and then we're going to move it way far
back and obviously these stairs leave a
little bit to to be desired in terms of
where they're going but if i grab the
handle in the upper corner watch this we
can increase their length
we can increase their height
and the system just automatically
generates stairs for me so
we'll just connect those right up and
make a couple of quick edits there we go
that looks pretty good and we can also
make them wider so we'll just
slide that out like so i don't know why
it needed a sound effect but for some
reason i feel like it did now we can
also change the number of stairs as well
so i can take the step height and you
can see i can adjust that we can make
these into floating stairs uh let's make
sure that they are creating some
collision and i i have to mention this
because it just it makes me so
fundamentally happy but if you get right
down on the stairs we can actually turn
on bevel we can add just a little bit of
bevel to the edge of the stairs which
really helps when the the light hits
them just so
if we're done if we're happy we can just
right click and go back to scripted
actor actions swap that out to a static
mesh and there we go we've built a new
part of the level of course it does have
this really cool prototyping grid
material but let's make it fit the scene
just a little bit better
we'll add some color to it we'll bring
in some red for the top area
and i'll make the stairs blue because
that's what i have handy and there we go
now
it'd be great if i also had some
armaments and we have access to the
entire gameplay library that makes lyra
so here is a weapon spawner and by the
way this is defined entirely in
blueprint so if i wanted to open this up
and change its behavior i could
i wouldn't even have to write a line of
code but all i'm going to do is change
some settings so let's take the weapon
definition and we'll set that over to
rifle and i'll take the color and set it
over to pink so that everybody knows
that this is my rifle and i'm the only
one who gets to use it
and if if i wanted to we could just test
this out so let's hit play
and i'll quickly run up the steps
and i know that bot is coming i can feel
it
come on
okay
oh they went upstairs all right well
let's take our bunker we'll grab our
rifle
now i got cover ah here we go yeah
that's right come on come on
i don't know why i'm adding sound
effects i can't help it
but see there you go just like that i
was able to change the overall flow of
the level from something very open and
frenetic to some place where i have
cover where i can pick up a weapon and
really try to to control the situation
and i did that using procedural tools
that are already included with lyra
now of course we're not limited to that
we have the entire epic games ecosystem
we have the marketplace we have
sketchfab we have quixil bridge there's
even art station and you can bring in
content from those and really make lyra
look like anything you want it to be so
here's a statue that we actually had
from a previous project so i could just
drag this in
and of course this looks great it has a
lot of fantastic detail but it doesn't
quite fit the overall flow of lyra so
let's just fix that i'll just drag a new
material on it surely no art director
would have a problem with that
but the point is that you can just add
whatever content your heart desires and
really start turning your lyra levels
into anything you want them to be
so now you've seen how you can build
your own games and experiences inside of
lyra and this was using just one of
three modes available inside the project
we have elimination which is like a
standard death match we have control
which is like a capture and hold mode
and there's even exploder which is like
a top-down party game and all of this is
available to you today
that's great zach thanks
even though this is the first release of
ue5 we've made sure the engine is ready
to ship projects from day one we're
proud of the demos we built to drive
development of unreal engine 5 lumen in
the land of nanite valley of the ancient
for our early access release and the
matrix awakens available to players
around the world on xbox series x and
series s and playstation 5.
but to really put the engine through its
paces last december we shipped chapter 3
of fortnite on unreal engine 5 across
all platforms pc ps4 and ps5 xbox one
series x and series s nintendo switch
and android
we completed a rigorous process
comparing the performance memory and
stability of fortnite on ue5 with
fortnite on ue4
and we were able to make the transition
smoothly without any major modifications
to fortnite's code or content
and the fortnite team was able to take
advantage of the new editor and
workflows in ue5 having taken the plunge
ourselves you can be confident that ue5
is battle tested and ready for
production
now our goal has always been for all
developers to be able to take advantage
of ue5 whether you're already working in
ue4 or starting anew
we made sure the path to transition from
ue4 to 5 is straightforward and well
documented so you can hit the ground
running with all of the new features
right away
this is just the beginning future
updates will include new features
improvements and optimizations and we're
arming you with an arsenal of libraries
and additional tools with the power of
creation in your hands day one
to preview some of these incredible
tools let's go to our friends at epic
stockholm in sweden
hey everyone teddy here
high quality food reel content is
incredibly expensive and time consuming
to create our mission is to bring you
vast libraries of high quality assets
already made for you and awesome tools
for creating your own photoreal content
and digital humans more quickly than
ever before so that you can concentrate
on what matters most creating amazing
experiences i founded qixel over a
decade ago with the vision to build mega
scans a massive library of ready-made
fold real assets to simplify digital
world creation for developers
all built with state-of-the-art scanning
technology a single such asset contains
millions of triangles and in the past
making use of such high fidelity content
to create billion polygon scenes was
limited to the motion picture industry
and could simply not be done in games
but now with the advent of unreal engine
5 and nanite micro polygon geometry it's
finally possible to use this movie
quality content as is to create
real-time experiences that are
indistinguishable from reality
regardless of which industry you're in
when kwiksel joined epic we immediately
made the entire mega scans library free
for use with unreal engine and started
work on integrating it into the engine
itself to enable you to use all these
incredibly high fidelity assets directly
in engine with the release of unreal
engine 5 you can now access the world's
largest library of the highest quality
scans for free fully and anti-compatible
without ever having to leave the editor
with a simple drag and drop you can
instantly stream in full real nanai
content to build any world imaginable
and if you need even more assets and
can't find what you need in the mega
scans library or unreal engine
marketplace we join forces with both art
station and sketchfab working to make
millions of additional marketplace
assets more accessible to developers
we're solving the problem of content
creation at scale with libraries of free
assets and paid world-class assets from
creators featuring the best revenue
share in the industry
sometimes you might not find exactly the
assets you're looking for and would like
to create it yourself but take it from
me scanning custom assets has always
been incredibly hard work that requires
a great deal of training as well as
specialized and expensive hardware and
software
for this reason we've been working to
distill our scanning experience and
technology into an easy to use phone app
bringing the gold standard of
photogrammetry straight into your pocket
we're calling this app reality scan it
intelligently guides you through the
scanning process in ar to ensure optimal
quality
processes all data automatically in the
cloud and publishes the final assets
straight to sketchfab for use anywhere
all for free our goal is to make it as
easy as possible for you to create and
share your own custom for real content
whenever you need it for the exact same
reason we also released metahumancreator
a free cloud-based app that empowers
professionals as well as beginners to
create fortrealistic digital humans
complete with hair and clothing in
minutes this used to be incredibly
challenging and time consuming but now
you can create your own digital humans
at the quality of the best looking games
out there
so by combining this incredible free
creator ecosystem of best in class tools
and movie quality content with the power
of unreal engine 5 creating amazing
photo real games and experiences has
never been this easy
with all these new free tools you'll be
able to start building an exciting new
ways developed by both you and the
community as a whole
and to tell you more about another great
community resource here is schwart
thank you teddy
the community of creators all over the
world is something that is very dear to
us at epic
i started my personal journey when i
first discovered unreal engine 23 years
ago when i was just 15 years old
i started creating levels for arnold
tournament join his community and it
changed my life as we've seen it do for
so many others
we are excited to provide the engine and
our whole ecosystem of tools to everyone
but we're equally thrilled to ensure
that we equip creators with the
knowledge and support you need to
succeed
making as easy as possible to find and
share knowledge across the community
with the next generation of unreal
engine launching we have been working on
a new community site
dev.epigames.com
community the site brings together a
number of different community channels
and tools to make it easy to find all of
our resources in one place learning
content forums questions and answers and
code snippets
the learning section is a centralized
fully open and accessible library of all
kinds of courses tutorials live streams
and tech talks for you to browse through
and read or watch
and what i really like is that anyone
can write tutorials and contribute to
this library of content through an easy
to use tutorial editor
that lets you freely build up your page
using text image video and code widgets
if for example you discover how to do
amazing procedural animation using
control rig to add secondary motion to
your characters you can share those
learnings with other devs
the unreal engine forums have been fully
integrated in order to give you space to
showcase your cool projects discuss
things with other devs or to find
solutions from others
there is also the snippet repository to
share and store snippets of code such as
c plus and python or text-based assets
such as blueprint materials meta sounds
and so on
for example
in the lyra starter game one of our devs
made a blueprint setup that measures the
running speed of the player and then
uses that to drive reactive music via
metasound
if you have an interesting setup like
that you could simply copy and paste
that from the anvil editor to the
snippets on the site and by doing so
store things you would like to remember
or more importantly
share with others so that they can use
your work as a foundation
and lastly activity is captured and
represented through your profile that
you can personalize to represent who you
are and what you create
if you're looking to up your skills or
if you have questions and you need help
with something or perhaps simply to show
your awesome work or discoveries come
and join us in the unrelenting community
at
death.epicgames.com
community
i'm always so inspired by all the
amazing work that is being created by
everyone around the world
we count ourselves fortunate to be able
to give back to our amazing community in
the form of mega grants and fellowship
programs
today we are proud to highlight some of
the astounding work being produced by
the community and here's this example of
all that amazing work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is awesome to see so many inspiring
projects from game developers filmmakers
and creators of animated entertainment
lifting up their voices and vision
through the power of unreal engine
we are thrilled to confirm that all of
the amazing studios you see here are a
part of the unreligion five community
which continues to grow every day
this represents an insanely talented
population of creative technical talent
spanning thousands of people across the
planet who are working on just about any
and every type of project you can think
of and many of these teams are hiring
this year officially marks 20 years of
unreal engine on xbox along with
unprecedented adoption of unreal engine
across microsoft's internal teams who
are building games that the industry
will be talking about for the next 5 10
15 years
and that leads us to a world-class
studio that is very dear to epic the
coalition the team behind the gears
franchise they have been instrumental in
helping the rubber meet the road where
it really counts
it is my pleasure to turn it over to
kate raynor and colin penty
we've been working with unreal engine 5
for over a year now and
we've already seen a lot of the benefits
our relationship with epic has really
impacted positively the gears of war
franchise whether it's collaboration or
calls about various systems or
contributing code we've been creating
numerous prototypes and demos and we're
happy to show you some of the results
today
what you're seeing now is our alpha
point demo it was an early access demo
that we showed at gdc in 2021
there are a few different components an
abbreviated character cinematic and a
early large world technical test
the open world tech test was built to
test a few things it was built to test
the landscape system how does it react
with nanite
how does world partition streaming
function
and how do these all come together and
perform on xbox
[Music]
so metahumans came out about halfway
through our character rendering visual
tech test demo and so we immediately
sort of stopped what we were doing for a
bit took a look at metahumans and wanted
to see how it could augment our existing
character that we were building and so
we pulled things like materials from
metahumans and eyeballs and teeth and
bring it all together and just see what
level of fidelity we could hit throwing
all the latest tech and unreal engine 5
at it
this cinematic demo brings the character
quality of the new rendering systems the
environment technologies the new lumen
rendering system
all together to create a real-time
cinematic experience that goes beyond
anything that we've done in the past
i'm personally very proud of them they
were all sort of labors of love for
myself and the art team and engineering
teams and really opened our eyes towards
what the next gen quality visual bar
could be and so it was a huge learning
experience for us and i think it
actually set us up really well when epic
came and asked for help on the matrix
awakens demo the fact that we were able
to ship
this experience on xbox series s with
all the same features including ray
tracing that we had on the xbox series x
at such a high quality level
is really amazing
with the launch of unreal engine 5 what
i'm most excited for is the developer
efficiency that we have for our team we
really are able to deliver a aaa
experience
that we've always wanted to without the
compromises
unreal engine 5 i feel like is a huge
game changer and i feel like we haven't
fully even realized how much of a game
changer it's going to be it basically
democratizes game development across the
world and yes there's accelerations for
aaa developers like ourselves but also
is a great uh
entry point for indie dev studios and so
i think it furthers along unreal engine
4's vision of everyone can build a
project and build a game and i think
it's going to change the entire industry
thanks so much kate and collin the work
across microsoft and the coalition make
unreal engine better for everyone
cd projekt red are experts in open world
game design with the witcher 3 and
cyberpunk 2077 combining freedom of
exploration with compelling storytelling
in unparalleled fashion through a new
partnership with epic cd projekt bread
is building a brand new witcher saga
with ue5
our cooperation with epic has just
started it was uh the shift towards uh
open world support that brought
unrelenting five to our attention
so there was one demo that happened last
year that was the medieval environment
demo where
at one point uh there's a notice board
that looks strangely familiar to things
we've done in the past that has even a
sign that says monster slayer wanted and
i'm like hmm are they are they trying to
tell us you know come come over to
unreal engine look how great your games
could look on there is that was that
whole demo made with that nefarious
purpose i don't know but it definitely
definitely caught my eye
this opens a new chapter for us where we
really want to see how our experience in
building open world games it's combined
with all the engineering power of epic
one of the things that is really
important to keep in mind when when
talking about open world games versus
let's say linear games is
the possibilities of the things that can
go wrong or the the scenarios that you
have to consider are
exponentially higher than linear games
players can go in whatever direction
that they want they can handle content
in in any order that they want
theoretically and to really encapsulate
that means that you need a really stable
environment where you can be able to
make changes with a high level of
confidence that it's not going to break
in 1600 other places down the line
unreal engine is like a toolbox which
has a lot of features a lot of solutions
already there that allow teams to just
try new stuff the fact that unreal is
used by a lot of teams already in the
world a lot of perspectives are
projected into the design of the tools
and that helps the tool to be way more
agile so all in all it's a really really
cool technology to like prototype and
make environments really quickly
really beautiful and very realistic
epic and cd projekt red are the two
companies that really want to achieve
something great we won't stop just you
know by
developing some features we won't stop
there yeah we will continue to work
together to achieve something
extraordinary in the end
thank you to the cd projekt red team for
providing this great insight into why
you are placing your bets on ue5
we've touched upon how great
storytellers are turning to unreal and
this applies to many different
disciplines whether you're a game
designer or a cinematographer that
common language that real time parlance
is unreal engine 5.
few people understand this better than
aaron sims
unreal engine 5 allows for a creative to
be able to create anything that they've
dreamed of into reality
after being in the industry for over
three decades i've seen a lot of changes
in the visual effects industry
i've seen a lot of great innovations but
there's been nothing like unreal engine
5. i think it's still new to the
community in some ways as far as looking
at it as a storytelling tool a lot of
people think of it as a game tool or
other things i think that there's so
much capacity for storytelling
[Music]
so what was exciting working on valley
of the ancient
it was our first look at unreal engine 5
and all the different tools were amazing
but the control rig is one aspect that i
think is really exciting
it's so important to actually have
realistic movement not only the look and
feel and the lighting of the character
but the movement has to be realized in a
way that as the audience you believe
them
and so you have all the tools using
control rig the face rig
and being able to use mocap for me was a
lifesaver and to be able to bring it in
engine and just rework a few things here
and there and i was done
all in unreal
is pretty amazing
the great thing again about unreal it's
a lot of fun to be able to play within
that sandbox
and what's also important is to be able
to have access to assets
[Music]
the marketplace is a great resource
there's a lot of free content
and we as a matter of fact actually
added to that library and it's a
creature from our film called the i
calendar
many humans created this ability to have
an artist tell their story with a human
character and believe them
the fact that the shaders and the
textures the skin is very realistic
and even the hair and the eyes and
everything have really taken
the human character to the new level
when you thought about making a film or
making a story i think those
limits that used to be
you can actually put those away
the fact that a small group of people
can create a stunning worlds that are
believable and characters that have so
much emotion
and be able to tell compelling stories
there's nothing like unreal engine 5
it's an artist's dream
thanks erin we are blown away by your
work and the sky is the limit moving
forward we are thrilled to be working
with so many incredible partners who are
using unreligion 5 to move the state of
the art forward
in fact we have one more friend to
introduce
thanks dana
crystal dynamics is proud to be a part
of the launch of unreal engine 5.
this new engine translates into next
level storytelling and gameplay
experiences
and that's why we are thrilled to
announce today that we have just started
development of our next tomb raider game
powered by unreal engine 5.
our goal is to push the envelope of
fidelity and to deliver the high quality
cinematic action adventure experience
that fans deserve from both crystal
dynamics and the tomb raider franchise
we can't wait to take this journey
together
thank you and congratulations again to
the epic games team
wow thanks dallas we can't wait to see
what the next chapter of tomb raider
holds so with the end of this very
exciting hour let's recap unreal engine
5 is out and available today in addition
to the lyra starter game an awesome
project you can use to build and ship
your first ue5 game not to mention
thousands of free assets from the matrix
awakens buildings meta humans vehicles
everything you need to get going
building dynamic open worlds
all of this is free to download and use
and be sure to check out the brand new
community hub for even more resources
and to help you get going and connect
with other developers
let's build the future together
[Music]
hello i'm jerome plateau the architect
of the special project team
welcome to the talk matrix awakens
creating a world
epic has been pushing the limit of
real-time rendering and demonstrating
that only engine can be used for many
types of projects from interactive
experience to linear content this year
we have created the experience name
matrix awakens
let's look at the teaser and then i'll
go over the goals and the ideas behind
the project
[Music]
hi
i'm thomas anderson
like many of you i work with computers
but computers are also mirrors
reflecting back who and what we are in
the choices we make
the worlds we
build got it
[Applause]
okay so let's go over the goals
first of all we want to make sure unreal
engine is ready for open world
experience
being able to stream large environment
and have all the tools ready to manage
such a big amount of data
then of course we want to use nanite and
lumen for man-made environment like a
city
we also have to create a new mass ai
system to populate the world with crowd
and car traffic
then we use the meta sound system to
bring everything to life like every year
we want to keep pushing our meta human
technology like the way we render it and
also the way we capture it
then we want to keep pushing our physics
system chaos to simulate the car physics
the crashes and the destructions
another important part is that we wanted
to utilize the gameplay system to
generate cinematic content
for example the cinematic artists could
use the playable cars and record
themselves driving around the city and
use those texts for cinematic shots
we also wanted to push our procedural
tools and workflow so that a relatively
small team can generate and populate a
large scale environment
then we will need this incredible
experience to run on consumer hardware
and put it in people's hands
we had to make sure that everybody who
owns the next gen consoles can see what
annual engine is capable of
and prove that those innovative
technology are available right now for
anybody who wants to use an oil engine 5
for their project
over the years we've been creating tech
demos to showcase the latest engine
features but most importantly is to make
sure that those new tools have been
tested on real production
now that we have established the goals
let's see what are the idea behind the
demo
we got in touch with lana wakovsky just
before she started to film the matrix
resurrection
we talked about the project with her and
she was ready to jump on it right after
she finished filming the movie
the matrix universe was a perfect match
for us to talk about the future of
graphics and simulated world
the key part was that we wanted to blur
the lines between cinema and game the
experience starts with a mix of
real-time cinematic and live-action
photography
then little by little we added more and
more gameplay then we finish on the open
world where the player can go back and
explore the entire city where the
experience just happened
now that the demo has been published and
unreal engine 5 has been released we
want to give away the entire city to the
unreal engine community
you can download the full project in the
epic launcher in the unreal engine
marketplace
all the assets are available for free
and you can reuse them for your own
project
let's go over a few numbers the city is
made of thousands of modular pieces
those pieces have on average 50 000 to
500 000 polygons
all the assets are nanite except when
they are being deformed or need to have
transparent shaders on the texture side
we try to stick with 4k texture
resolution
if we need more resolution we break the
uvs into several udims and add more 4k
textures
all the textures are converted to
virtual textures
and of course like most of our project
we try to leverage the awesome mega scan
library i'm going to hand it over to
virg who is going to dive deeper into
the project
hello
my name is watch levi
i'm a senior technical artist in the
special projects group at epic games
today i'm going to take you on a tour of
the asset and content pipeline we used
to create the city
in the matrix awakens
the first thing we did was discuss what
we wanted the city to look like an urban
cityscape with tall skyscrapers and two
main city sections
we wanted a detail rich city with a
variety of iconic buildings throughout
the city
we drew inspiration from san francisco
chicago and new york
we looked for buildings with intricate
detail at both the bird's eye and also
at the street level
we also wanted buildings we could mix
and match using the upper section of one
building with the lower section of
another
we also identified specific
building and street props signage that
we liked awnings you know anything that
we could fit onto the facade wall of a
building we identified 24 unique
buildings
10 chicago 8 new york and 6 san
francisco themed
we also included one building from the
quixote megascans library to ensure our
system and tools would work with module
buildings from any source with our
billions of props identified the next
step is to build a content library in
unreal
this library would feed the houdini
based procedural city generator
the results of the city generator would
then be brought back into unreal to
create the final city result
we now break down our asset pipeline
into its individual components we have
our content library which feeds the
houdini city generator we then return
into unreal
where we spawn the results of the city
generator the first assets we started
building in the content library were our
buildings utilizing nanite we wanted to
capture as much geometry detail as
possible we included building
imperfections wear damage and bevels in
the base geometry no displacement
required
all this detail meant it would be
prohibitive to construct the buildings
as a single static mesh
the triangle count would be incredibly
high and while nanite could handle the
triangle counts
a single static mesh would limit our
ability to create building variations
we went back to the reference and took a
closer look in keeping the ideal nanite
workflow in mind buildings have a lot of
repetition in windows and walls
and are a perfect case for instancing we
wanted to be able to reuse the buildings
as much as possible to create detail and
variation across the city we devised a
plan to slice the buildings into
individual modular components
if we slice out just right we would be
able to instantiate the modules into an
unlimited amount of unique building
shapes so we took the reference images
and started defining the modules
required to make the buildings we
organized the modules by level with a
consistent cut line all modules within a
level would be exactly the same height
it's just a construction block game
super easy right
well buildings are complex
and have a lot of unique features and
it's these features that make our
reference buildings look interesting to
capture all the detail requires a lot i
mean a lot of unique modules while
slicing up the buildings we started to
realize that even the simple buildings
had hidden complexity real world
buildings are built to fit within a
specific terrain or location we found
that features in the building often
varied from one side of the building to
the other from a distance the modules
all appear to be the same size
but actually many modules that look the
same
are many feet different in width
and none of the buildings had a base
module size that matched a consistent
grid we reduced the overall module count
by consolidating modules with similar
size
we merged columns and windows or made
double wide modules whenever possible
we felt it was the variety of detail and
the inconsistencies of size and shapes
that made these reference buildings look
interesting so we strive to retain all
modules with differences in detail so
that we could recreate the buildings as
close to the original as possible using
our base modules
once we had all the module shapes
defined for building style we used a
custom built module template generator
to create a proxy version of each module
the template generator also allowed for
defining
additional metadata for the module
including module name
variation
floor
and dimensions
all the module templates are organized
into a building kit that represents all
the modules required to recreate the
building we use these templates as a
starting point to create each building
style and began prototyping the
procedural building we also use these
template modules as a starting point in
maya to create high resolution geometry
the templates represented the base shape
and dimensions of the module but not
necessarily the bounding box of the
module additional features could push
out from the bounds of the template
geometry this is why we opted to use
dimensions derived from the template
geometry rather than rely on bounding
boxes of the high resolution geometry
for module dimensions
many of the buildings have hundreds of
template modules and hundreds of
high-res modules
in order to keep our assets consistent
and our team sane we developed a custom
importer to batch import the building
modules create the necessary folder
structures and create and assign
material instances for each module for
more information on this tool please
check out our talk on building look
development in total we created 24
unique buildings for a combined
2333 unique high-res meshes
2558 unique textures and a whopping
577 material instances it's a lot of
data and we needed a way to keep it all
organized i've mentioned kits a few
times so far
so what the heck is a kit
think of it like a lens kit or a shaving
kit a kit is a single location to
organize all of the building modules a
quick way to review the module's
geometry the look development
and to see how all the pieces fit
together to make a building
these kits lasted the entire life of the
project and were used as the work area
to develop the buildings so what exactly
are the building modules
we defined a base set of modules
corner wall and entrance this base set
can be used to create any basic building
we also added some additional modules
required to lay out more complex facades
wall caps are designed to finish off a
repeating wall module segment and are
often polarized for the left or right
side of the building
transition modules sit in between two
modules that may be offset from each
other they are also designed to be
scaled to fit gaps
pillars and columns are specific
features that may go between window or
wall modules and should not be scaled at
all
corners are broken into a few separate
modules the base corner modules are
interior and exterior and are required
for buildings with 90 degree or square
corners we also defined split left and
right corner modules to support acute
and obtuse corners split corners seem
like a perfect solution however
they only work for flat edge corners
details that extend past the corner will
penetrate on obtuse angles and will
create gaps on acute angles to avoid
gaps we developed a new corner type we
call corner caps corner caps act almost
like a hinge and are aligned to the
average angle of both the left and right
wall segments in most cases we were able
to reuse 90 degree corners as corner
caps
but on building styles with lots of
facade detail we had to create custom
corner caps
we also found that corner caps offered
another level of additional detail and
variation especially on building targets
that contain lots of corners
now that we have all our building
modules defined we need to assemble them
to create a facade we wanted artists to
have control over how the facades would
be procedurally generated so we created
an expression language we called shape
grammar that describes the construction
of a facade wall
shape grammar allows for explicit
placement of building modules but also
supports repeating segments looping
segments and defining which modules can
be scaled shape grammar also supports
describing vertical segments of a
building
ground level in blue
is the base of a building and is
explicitly placed
red segments are also explicitly placed
and cannot be repeated
green levels can be repeated
the last level in purple is a topper and
placed to finish the vertical segment at
the top of the building
the vertical shape grammar defines which
levels can be repeated which part of the
building can be split into different
styles
and how to finish a wall segment by
placing a topper module
to find out more about shape grammar
check out our procedural tech talk
to achieve aesthetic placement of
building props we opted to hand place
prop anchors on modules
props are registered to modules and
groups that allow for random selection
of a prop anchor during procedural city
generation
props are organized by type awning light
fixture sign
and by brand bank burger joint hotel
in our prop library when a building is
procedurally generated a random prop
brand is selected for the building
facade
when an individual prop is placed on a
building a random selection of
variations is chosen from each prop type
keeping track of module metadata became
incredibly important as mentioned
earlier bounding box dimensions alone
are not a reliable method to determine
module size we use the hoodie template
generator to create all the module
metadata and store the module
information houdini engine converted the
module attributes to tags and stored
them on the staticmesh object where the
metadata could be easily retrieved later
down in the pipeline
pivot location is also a critical path
and crucial to keep consistent
we decided to place the pivot on the
left side of a module aligned to the
forward leading edge of a wall facade
with the pivot aligned to the wall we
would always know where the wall existed
on the facade
however this did create some challenges
for modules that did not have a
forward-facing wall like a recessed
entrance or a stepped back wall
we still place the pivot where the
phantom wall would have been
all of the module information including
shape grammar and level grammar is
recorded in a json formatted building
definition file this file was saved
externally from unreal engine and used
by houdini to construct a procedural
building we thought of the pdf files as
the building style as it represented
everything required to construct a
building of a particular style so far in
the asset pipeline we have defined how
the building modules and the building
props content was created
we have imported into unreal and
organized the content into kits
we have assigned metadata and registered
props to the building modules and
generated a building definition file
that contains all the information
required to define a building style at
this point we are ready to send the file
over to the procedural system and
generate a building
procedural buildings can be generated in
both houdini and in real engine using
the city building generator hda we
relied heavily on the building generator
in unreal engine at all phases of
building development to ensure our
modeling materials and look dev was set
up to work properly in the procedural
system
please check out the procedural city
generation for more talk on the building
generator we also hand authored
collections of props to scatter around
the city at street level and on the
rooftops of buildings we call these hand
authored assets biomes
we hand authored the biomes using a new
unreal engine 5 feature called level
instant pack blueprints
packed blueprints can be created from
any selection of actors
the selection is exported into a newly
created level that contains only the
selection
and a packed blueprint is generated from
that level all automatically
all actors are converted to ism
components within the packed blueprint a
really nice feature in this workflow is
the ability to place a packed blueprint
in a level and then edit it in place
we use the packed blueprint workflow to
author all biomes hero buildings and
hero areas of the city hero buildings
and biomes are also fed into the city
generator for procedural placement
around the city
with our source contact pipeline
complete we are now ready to generate
all the buildings in the city to see how
that's done check out the procedural
tech talk
once the city is generated a point cloud
is saved into an alembic file we call
the olympic file a pvc as it only
contains point information and any
procedurally generated geometry required
to create the buildings streets and
collision objects
it's not a fully formed olympic file
that contains the full city
so it's just points and data
we bring this ppc back into unreal
and spawn the city using the rule
processor spawning the city is a complex
task the city contains thousands of
buildings props roads decals biomes
information to build a traffic system
parked cars and place audio around the
city it's a tremendous amount of
information
so how do we spawn the city and manage
all of these actors
welcome to open world open world is a
new set of tools in unreal engine 5 that
allow for managing large complex worlds
and for efficiently streaming these
worlds at runtime the two main features
in the new open world toolkit are world
partition
and one file per actor
world partition is a grid system that
allows for the loading and unloading of
actors in editor and spatially at
runtime it removes the necessity of
sub-levels and complex logic to set up
when areas of the world are active
one file per actor separates the
connection between actors and levels
and allows for multiple people to work
on a level at the same time
one fault for actor also works in
conjunction with world partition to
enable loading and unloading of
individual actors world partition
also introduces a new organizational
system called data layers
data layers are essentially a way to
group content with a common label that
can be toggled on or off and streamed at
run time when world partition streaming
cells are turned on or off
in the editor world partition improved
workflows and iteration times massively
for our content team
by allowing them to only load the
streaming cells and data layers that
they needed at any given moment one file
per actor stores each actor in the map
as its own file on disk
which means when we edit the world
data contention between team members is
at a minimum because only a minimal set
of data is locked for instance
i'd only have to load the single cell or
data layer containing the stop sign and
check out only that one actor to make
the change
and i wouldn't have to lock other folks
out of an entire sub-level level
instances are also a new feature in
world partition
they offer a level-based workflow that
facilitates the porting of non-world
partition worlds into a world partition
system
they offer a fast workflow for creating
pack blueprints
pack blueprints are great because they
they allow artists to abstract work from
the main world partition map and work in
an isolated area creating content that
can then be brought into the world
partition map and edited in context
the large city is roughly four
kilometers square
this is not a constraint of open world
we chose the city size for creative
reasons only
there are a total of one hundred and one
thousand 959 actors
in the world partition map
this count does not include traffic
crowds or any other runtime elements
this number represents individual actors
saved as one file per actor total
instances contained in all ism
components is eight million five hundred
and fifty six thousand seven hundred and
thirty two
this is all the building modules props
stickers roads traffic lights decals
everything that is instantiated in the
city
data layers are split into runtime and
editor components
runtime data layers have the ability to
be controlled by logic at runtime and
editor data layers are used for world
management in editor only and have no
runtime overhead
world partition for the large city is
set up with a main grid and two h-lot
grids
the main grid contains everything within
128 meters from the player this includes
all the original actors that are placed
in editor
data layers can be used to control the
loading and unloading of actors at run
time
hlot 0 represented in blue
is the grid range extending up to 768
meters
all cells within the range from 128
meters to 768
will load hlot 0 with respect to data
layers h log 0 contains 4 actors that
are generated per cell
all the actors
in the main grid cell are merged into 4
separate actors and consolidated into
ism components
this reduces the overall actor count and
improves streaming of the cells
since h slot 0 is generated from the
main grid actors whenever a change is
made to the actors in the main grid hlot
0 will need to be regenerated
we used an automated process to
regenerate hlot 0 every night
h log 1 represented in red
is visible past the 768 meter range and
is always loaded in memory h-log one
takes all the static meshes in a cell
and merges them into a single nani mesh
just like h lot zero any changes to the
main grid will require regeneration of
hloud one
all handcrafted and procedurally
generated buildings
are constructed using ism components
this reduced overall actor count in the
city
and improved streaming performance
we did split all the buildings into
upper and lower sections to improve
collision
the lower ground section of a building
uses articulate collision objects per
building module to allow for detailed
collision this allows players to walk
into recessed entrances of buildings and
also walk through covered hallways and
corridors
these collision objects are nested
within the static mesh for each module
and instanced along with the module
inside the ism component
for the upper section of buildings we
disabled collision on the building
modules
a separate primitive collision object
that represented the entire collision
section is placed as a separate actor
this allowed for only evaluating a
single primitive collision object for
the entire upper section of a building
to improve retracing performance we set
up retracing groups per building this
helped optimize the lumen surface cache
and allows all the pieces of a building
to be called together
when setting up the groups avoid
including sparse objects the goal of the
group is to group objects that are close
together
to further improve ray tracing
performance we made sure there was very
little overlap of meshes
hardware ray tracing gets slow when
meshes are kit patched together and have
lots of internal occlusions and
penetrations
we booleaned all of our building modules
to remove any dirty geo
lumen traces mesh instances close to the
camera and then relies on h-lot one for
everything else allowing gi over huge
distances
now that we understand open world it's
time to set up the rule processor and
spawn the city
the rule processor is a set of tools
that allow for importing point data via
analymic file
this point data could come from any
source
for this project we exported olympic
point data from houdini and also from
unreal engine for use with the rule
processor
the rules can be very simple for each
point spawn an actor or the rules can be
complex if a point is an upper level
building module assign it to the
building data layer disable collision
and set the window primitive data the
rule processor is fast and able to
process millions of points very quickly
we were able to respawn the entire city
around 50 times throughout the project
and often we respond the entire city
multiple times per day we set up
multiple rules for ingesting the city
based on how we wanted to organize
actors in the world
buildings have a set of very specific
rules that are different from actors
that make up the roads and freeways
setting up separate rules for different
assets that made up the city allowed us
to only regenerate those specific assets
when things changed further speeding up
the process
the rule processor keeps track of actors
that have been spawned and automatically
cleans up old actors it's also smart and
recycles actors to reduce ads and
deletes when using source control
the rule processor is also able to look
up metadata key values and apply that
data to actors as attribute overrides
this was helpful for setting up actors
with specific needs like mesh decals and
collision objects
the metadata required for setting up the
interior windows was also procedurally
generated and set up on actors as per
instance primitive data
the city is spawned and ready for
gameplay
this project was an absolute joy to work
on
before coming to epic i worked in the
film industry for 20 years
and this is the first project i've
worked on that didn't rely on a render
farm to produce final frames
working with assets at this level of
detail fidelity and complexity in real
time was something i never would have
imagined was possible just a few years
ago and every time i fire up my
workstation and open up the city map it
blows my mind what we're able to do now
thanks for watching this video
and if you want to know more about how
this city was produced please check out
our procedural tech talk
hey i'm scott clifford and i'm a
principal technical artist in the
special projects group at epic games in
this section i'll be showing you some of
the techniques as well as unreal engine
5 features that contributed to the look
and feel of the matrix awakens city
environment
okay fellow friends of unreal here we go
as we narrowed in on the content for the
matrix awakens we were faced with
populating a city with buildings we
wanted these buildings not only to have
the complex model detail we can support
with nanite but also high levels of
realistic shading detail across a
variety of architectural styles
so we start as all good look dab does
with some photo reference of the style
of a building that fits the project
here's an example of the entrance of a
building we chose for reference
this building not only needs to look
good from this scale but it needs to
look good at the scale of a city
it also needs to look good from a human
scale
and possibly even from an arm's length
scale
oh yeah and there are 18 buildings that
we've scouted and would like to include
in our city
as watch spoke about earlier after we
break that the building down we're not
talking about just shading a building
we're talking about shading modular
pieces of a building
for instance good old building chd has
72 modules in its kit
but that's kind of a simple building
chc has 226 modules
and nya 485 modules
so we end up with over 2 000 individual
pieces of buildings that need shading
challenge accepted
our goals are to minimize repetition
create textures for thousands of module
assets with a small team
accommodate all possible module
arrangements and maintain our pbr values
in our final materials
not so fast
anytime we want to do look dev we need
to have a calibrated lighting setup that
we trust to make judgments about the
work we're doing
this is a topic that could be its own
tech talk in itself but some of the
things that we consider are what kind of
hdri we're using for our our sky
illumination what is the key fill ratio
of the sun to the sky and how does that
relate to what we see in the hdri
what are our post-process volume
settings
and many other details that you can
check out in the citysample asset pack
where we include this calibrated
lighting setup
so now let's break down the look
when doing look dev on a model we can
break the process down into three
distinct phases
the first step phase is where we address
the base substance what is this model
made of then we break it down to the
manufacturing process
how has the process that this building
was made or assembled with affected its
look
finally how has the environment changed
this building since it's been
manufactured
so let's start with our base substance
these substances are created by
gathering a library of tiling textures
that we start with from quixote mega
scans
we adjust these textures to possibly
remove repetition or add features
and then we export them as packed 4k
rgba images
we import these images as virtual
streaming textures into the engine
when we use virtual streaming textures
we remove limits on the number of
textures that we have in memory so we're
free to call as many textures as we want
and then we can manage that texture
performance by tuning the streaming pool
size per compression type
we then can create a ue material where
we apply these textures as world aligned
or tripliner and we use realistic
scaling to maintain the detail
at a believable scale
so here we are we get our first glimpse
of where we're going the building
modules are assembled into coherent
buildings where we can start to test our
work in our calibrated lighting level
warning
even though we don't have anything close
to a finished material here it's
important that we start to sanity check
our albedo roughness specular and other
values with each layer of the material
i like to do this by keeping the pixel
inspector open
and comparing what the reference values
for things like base color and the g
buffer are to values that i know
so this is where we are it doesn't look
great but we have a starting point so
let's give ourselves a check for our
base substance and move on to our
manufacturing
the manufacturing details such as mortar
lines and block color variation can be
derived from two block pattern maps
block variation which gives each brick
in the pattern a different value and
mortar lines which shows where the
blocks are joined
at this point we could decide to fire up
a 3d paint package hand off these
textures and have our poor texture
artists paint these maps onto all 2000
building modules
however what we'd end up with is every
module having the same pattern in every
place it's used this doesn't give us
variation when the same module is used
many times in a building which is one of
the goals we started with
so maybe there's another way
before we get to that we also added a
couple crevice masks to the block
patterns where staining or drips might
be heavier
we'll use these later when we consider
how fabrication details affect the
environment's influence on our look
so we take our block pattern textures
and combine them into a single 4k pack
texture using bc7 texture compression
we use this compression to try to
maintain as much detail in each channel
and avoid channels bleeding together
during the compression process
we carefully inspect all our reference
and determine that we would need a
collection of five stone block patterns
and three brick patterns to cover the
architectural style found in our city
but how are we going to store all these
patterns
let's talk about udem textures for a
second
udem is simply an automatic uv offset
system that assigns an image into a
specific uv tile
so the mapping between the number that
is found in the image file name is then
used to offset that image into uv space
this allows us to use multiple low
resolution texture maps producing a
higher resolution result without using a
single ultra high resolution image
ue supports union texture imports and
stores them as virtual textures
we take our block patterns and each
pattern gets 10 variations in a 2x5 grid
each variation has identical bricks at
the left and right edges
this is going to help solve the problem
of building modules that are aligned
next to each other
we line up these 2x5 grids in a single
10 by 5 udem virtual texture
it's time to uv the modules what we do
here is a trim sheet approach where we
carefully unwrap our modules and lay out
the uv islands on our giant udim block
pattern with the goal of producing
modules with fabrication details that
can seamlessly tile with multiple
different neighbors
we lay out all islands in the bottom row
they will be procedurally offset into
the other variation roles in the
material we use style columns that are
two tiles wide so module islands could
be large and cross the border of two
tiles
most modules use two to three types of
block to achieve the right structure
now in our material we add functionality
to use these block pattern udim textures
for borderline color
also for per block based substance
variations of color and normal
we use per instance random to pick
different rows of udims and remove block
variation and repetition
we end up with four udem virtual
textures that provide all the brick and
block patterning for all 2000 plus
building modules
using 4k tiles for the block pattern
udim provides very high textile density
for fine details like mortar lines which
can be seen in the image on the left
being creative with the uv layout allows
artists to add complex structure to very
intricate geometry and variation is
automatically built in to every building
so let's see how we're doing here's our
reference against our first two layers
of our material which include the base
substance and the manufacturing detail
not bad so let's give ourselves a check
for that
and we'll move on to the final layer
which is the environment influence on
our building
for this we lay out an additional
standard set of uvs
and use a constant textile density
across all udim tiles
we recommend to use constant tile size
we did not do this where we had some
tiles in our udems which were 4k and
some were 2k which becomes difficult to
track as the textures go between
different departments so we recommend
you choose one size say 4k and have
every image in your udim be that size
also thoughtful layout of udims can be
used to pass information into materials
for instance on the right you can see
that we've broken down our materials
into stone on the bottom
painted materials in the middle and
glass on the top
so now that we have our uvs we can go
ahead and bake some textures first we
bake a set of utility signals per module
that include multiple ao distances
curvature world space position and other
signals
we process these utility signals in a
dcc and output our environment masks
which we then pack into a single texture
we pay attention to how these signals
behave near module borders because we
don't want neighboring modules to have
sharp lines between them
we also can use a low textile density
because our details will be added in the
material
so here you see our crevice occlusion
edgewear drips and broad occlusion
this makes up our packed environment
mask
every building module needs one so there
are 2000 of them
luckily since this process can be
automated no artists were harmed in the
making of this texture
so now that we have our texture we can
continue to build our material
we use the packed end mask with multiple
scales of world-aligned tiling detail
and macro breakup
we create material functions for all of
our environmental influences including
grime and drips
here's a glimpse at that environment
material you can see that we use
material attributes to layer the
manufacturing and environmental layers
over the base
you can see this by the one spine that
kind of travels through the graph from
left to right below
we use material functions along this
spine to share these layers between
different materials for instance here's
our drips material function in the upper
right
so let's check back in with where we are
we started here
and now we're here
just a reminder that aside from the
precise uvs needed for the block details
everything else you see here is handled
procedurally no hand painting no placing
decals
here's a glimpse of where we are with
our building material at a few different
scales
so let's go ahead and give ourselves
that last check for our environment
layer of our material
now that we have our building material
we need to assign that material to all
of our instances
we start with the global material at the
top level which is the parent of
everything below
we then add instances at the global
level to set parameters that might be
changed across every block material in
the whole show
we also add an instance to set the kind
of textures for instance limestone in
this case
and then we add another layer which sets
a color
we then add an instance at the building
level if we wanted to change the color
specifically of chj we would address
that here
there are 18 of these one for each
building
we then add an instance at the kit level
which allows us to make changes per
floor of buildings
finally we have an instance for every
module in which we set the specific
environment packed texture that we need
to use for that module there are over
2000 of these one for every building
module
so with this many modules one might ask
how do we get all of this data into the
engine
we've automated this process by using an
asset ingest editor utility widget
this widget relies on a rigid source
folder structure for fbx and png files
it then provides the actions of
importing static meshes textures
building material hierarchies and
assigning textures to material instances
once we completed our building material
and began to examine it when we put it
into the world we noticed there was a
bit of a disconnect between the bottom
of the buildings and the sidewalks
we addressed this by building a flat
skirt mesh for all building modules
these meshes were then placed
procedurally by the building generator
prop system
so let's move on to our window interiors
here you can see an example of what we
created
the technique we employed begins with
interior mapping which is used to fake
3d geometry with parallax on flat 2d
cards
on the left you see some typical
interior mapped rooms these are from
robo recall
on the right you can see our matrix
awakens office interiors which include
simulated 3d furniture and non-uniform
room size
so let's compare some techniques to
achieve this look
on the left you can see a fake room
using interior mapping only and on the
right there's the actual geometry
if we do a capture of the interior
geometry and use bump offset we get an
effect that appears to have the objects
floating in the middle of the room but
they still seem rather flat
we can use parallax occlusion to give
these objects some depth but there are
still some pretty bad extrusion
artifacts
came up with what we call the 3d print
method to improve these techniques
let's break that down
in the 3d print method we start from the
back and do a bump offset for each layer
we test for depth intersection and
iterate forward through slices and then
we dither those slices together
the information we need to make this 3d
print method work are front and back
ortho scene captures as well as a front
and back depth
we combine the front and back depth into
a single texture lookup
so here we see our fake room remember
that's not there that's fake geometry
mapped on a card against the real
geometry on the right
so how can we handle non-square rooms
we place a grid guide into the room
encompassing the full dimensions of that
room
we then capture the scene and remap the
vertices into our one by one by one cube
space
we can then decompress this captured one
by one room in the material
the great thing about this is this
technique works with any size room
once we have our interior technology
squared away we can move on to a window
material that encompasses it and adds
more variation
we control things like room type light
state temperature blinds glass
properties etc
so how do we decide which windows go
where
in order to have an understanding of
what the building is and what how it's
laid out we author this room data in
houdini or ue plug-in and pack it into a
32-bit unsigned integer we have flags
for all the information the material
needs to figure out what type of room to
render in a window
we store that room data as per instance
custom data for each instance in a
building ism
then we consume this room data in the
window material using hlsl to unpack and
reconstruct each bit field
once the look of our building started
the shape up we turned our attention to
the roads
we started our road development using a
single tiling asphalt texture
you can see here that that has some
obvious problems where we can see the
repetition
our texture cell bombing material
function helps us break up tiling
repetition by altering the uvs within
the texture cells
its source is the cell texture you see
it right which is a colored voronoi
noise pattern as well as the edge detail
between those cells
so again here we see our initial attempt
at tiling asphalt
and here it is with our cell bombed
asphalt which basically removes all of
the tiling repetition
then we add some rubble to our asphalt
followed by cell bombed grime
cell bomb cracks
patches
tiling macro variation
deferred decals
and wetness
one of the issues we noticed when we
added our wetness layers was that the
wetness was showing up under the decals
the way that we fixed this was to set
the decal response to none for the road
material node
then in the material we could use the
apply debuffer node to composite the
debuffers into the material under the
wetness layer at the appropriate point
here is our road material with the
features i've outlined as well as others
such as the ability to add lane markers
and to deal with intersections
getting the road witness to look right
was one of the biggest challenges of
this material we used many inputs to get
a natural looking water pooling effect
this required two uv sets vertex color
information for blending problem areas
as well as a variety of lane and vehicle
textures and manipulations of uvs
blended with noise to achieve our final
result
here are some images of our completed
road material in the world
so let's turn to rooftops
our wave function collapse rooftops are
modular to avoid the uv nightmare we use
world-aligned projected textures but
some buildings are not xy aligned so we
need a way to keep the roof grid and
line details aligned with the edges of
the modules
you can see here that as we rotate the
building the grid lines on top of the
roof stay locked to the roof surface
we accomplish this using a z rotation
aligned world space texture projection
this projection sticks to the rotated
object's orientation but freely tiles in
x and y
we do this by calculating the actor's z
orientation and then rotating our
absolute world space by the calculated
amount
here are the material nodes for that
technique
so let's change gears and talk a little
bit about our dynamic global
illumination and reflection technology
we call lumen
here you can see a scene with lumen
activated
we immediately notice the effects of all
the light hitting the building facade
and bouncing back toward camera we see
that indirect light produces soft
shadows under the vehicles and is
responsible for all of the light under
the freeway we also see detailed
reflections on the vehicles
here we see the same scene with lumen
turned off
lumen on
looming off
we like to say that lumen helps us light
the shadows by providing real-time gi
and reflections
this was very important in our world
since we often have buildings blocking
the sun we had wet road reflections and
we have plenty of highway overpasses
that shatter the sky where there is no
direct illumination available underneath
lumen has also been extended to support
huge environments it has a massive view
range which is accomplished by tracing
to mesh instances at small distances and
tracing against h-lot at greater
distances
here we see lumen operating at city
scale where a shaft of light on a
building is clearly taken into account
in the indirect illumination of a
building all the way across the street
one of the most important parts of lumen
is that it is dynamic it instantly
updates so you have no lighting builds
you can change your time of day you can
have moving cars characters and
destruction that are all computed and
taken into account as the light is
bounced around and the reflections are
calculated
when this project started one of the
ideas was to have a night mode where we
would illuminate the city not by the sun
by many practical light sources
using lumen for night mode was a happy
accident which was discovered while
exploring the world with the sun and sky
off
it became clear that lit only by
millions of emissive window meshes and
no place light sources lumen was able to
propagate that lighting in a realistic
way to give the city a nighttime look
and finally lumen uses hardware
raytracing on consoles which allows high
quality reflections where characters are
represented
i hope this talk has helped you
understand how we use unreal engine 5 to
create the world of the matrix awakens
as this undertaking was very much a team
effort jerome vacher and i would like to
extend our thanks to all the talented
individuals at epic who contributed to
the work you've seen here
thank you for watching
hello i'm quentin marmier i'm a lead
technical artist for the special project
at epic game
and today we are going to present with
robert osborne and julia marchand how to
generate a world for the matrix awakens
experience
the procedural silly generation
so let's look together on how we have
created a fully procedural cd generator
using very few simple inputs like basic
splines we have created a tool that
could generate on the fly an
american-like city
we will describe how we have used
houdini and unreal to shape and
outdirect it to our needs and how we
have used pawn clouds and the new role
processor pipeline to generate it on a
daily basis
this is a living autonomous city four by
five kilometers wide with 260 kilometers
of streets and 512 kilometers of
furnished sidewalks more than 7 000
unique buildings 18 000 traffic vehicles
and 35 000 pedestrians aware of each
other and respecting traffic rules
we will go over the step-by-step process
that were required to make this work and
what were the constraints we have faced
how it generates quickly a virtual world
made out of 8 million nanite instances
that provides incredible amount of
detail from the smallest piece of trash
on the ground to the nuts and bolts at
the top of a building
and how we ended up regenerating that
city 53 times to refine its procedural
rules over and over and become what you
can explore today in the matrix awakens
experience we've tried to use the full
potential of nanite lumen open world
with unreal engine 5 to offer the most
detailed virtual experience we could
but first let's introduce one of the
main tools we have used in the creation
of our city
houdini from side effects
hello
my name is mai al
i'm the lead technical artist on the
sci-fi labs team first off i would like
to thank epic games for the pleasure of
doing this presentation together
i would also like to thank and
acknowledge my former talent porn
brushes sim
um my colleague demi pernude who have
contributed greatly to this
collaboration on the side of that site
side effects is the developer of houdini
a high-end comprehensive 3d solutions
platform with a procedural node-based
architecture
with more than 25 years of history
hidden is widely recognized in vfx
industry with more than one academy
scientific and technical awards
you can think of a hidden pipeline later
factory
nodes are like machines that perform
specific tasks
the machines can be chained together to
form sophisticated networks like
industrial assembly lines
the designs of disassembly lines are
entirely up to you
finally the pipelines can be streamlined
and utilized into factories
aka hdas
so all the controls you care about are
exposed and the rest is fully automated
what makes hidden special is you can go
from easy to understand low level tools
to a complex high level factory
that will look from the outside does
some sort of magic
the core purpose of a procedural
pipeline is to serve the artists
to give them more creative controls and
fewer headaches when they need to redo
work
more importantly a procedure pipeline is
also scalable
you can often accomplish more with fewer
people
as developers time is valuable
the architecture of hidden name makes it
possible to integrate the software's
compute power deep into the pipeline
a pipeline is about a lot more than
making 3d models
with houdini a lot of the user stories
that can be encapsulated as tasks can be
then translated into tools
these tools are developed with close
collaboration between teams decisions
are made together to address different
departments concerns such as what should
be on the ui and how should the data be
transferred when it comes to engine
deployment the tools are typically
packaged as hdas which you can use in
editor through heading engine plugin
with hidden engines now free commercial
licenses for unreal a larger team of
artists and level designers can directly
interact with hoodiness use maintained
by a smaller team of tool developers
in nutshell once the tools are created
and deployed to unreal they hold an
engine plotting or power these tools
inside the editor by talking to them in
the library in the background
on your machine or on phone machines
as a real-time developer we need to
start building your own procedure tools
certified labs is here to help
we're a small team but we create a large
collection of free and open source
hidden tools especially focused on
real-time pipelines as well as the
quality of life of developers you can
think of certified slabs as a public
extension of your own iodine team
because the tools we make are based on
the feedback of the terminology
and will make them so that they can be
shared with everyone in the community
with more than 200 tools and growing it
is not unlikely that when you need to
accomplish something we may have a
standardized tool for that
labs tools span everything from modeling
photogrammetry uvs texture generation
asset export third-party integrations
and more we also ship a certified slabs
on real plugging which contains script
and shaders that work with hooded assets
or just generic all-purpose utility
shaders
you can discover all these by
downloading sci-fi slabs latest daily
builds
thank you so much myo for this overview
of houdini
and now let's have a look to the matrix
awakens procedural city and how we have
done it
as a starting point we knew the matrix
hurricane would have to be an open world
a city that would be fully detailed and
very large at the same time
we established that a four to five
kilometer wide city would provide the
ideal playground for the experience that
we had in mind
we knew this environment would be the
base for a lot of department to work on
and that they will need to be provided
with updated data as we are modifying it
this had to be automated
we also knew that it would have to be
procedurally generated because of the
relative small size of our environment
team versus the cheer size and level of
detail we were aiming for
all of this was also considering that we
would use nanite technology nanite has
changed the game because it removed all
polygon limit and the resolution at
which we can have details now that one
meter square can have up to a million
triangles without worrying about
performances a city of 16 kilometer
squares would have 16 trillion triangles
this brings a new problem the size and
the amount of assets on this becomes a
limiting factor
also bigger assets means slower
iteration and less flexibility
we can't just brute force our way
through we have to find a smart way to
slice the world
early on we were considering the use of
openstreetmap but unfortunately the data
provides is arbitrary unique in size and
shape for any given place there is too
much work to translate and adapt and
that creates too many unique assets
same would go for the natural follow-up
of a pen street map creating a mega mesh
of the city but for the amount of detail
we were after that was a viable solution
what we need to do is quantify the world
and make our own construction set to
build it we would then relay as much as
possible on instancing
our work becomes then how to slice and
dice a realistic world and replicate it
the most precisely possible with those
bricks this is especially complex
because in the real world you will
always find a piece that is almost
impossible to reproduce with your bricks
that is where having full control over
the geometry of the city becomes so
important we wanted to keep a tight grip
on how much of the arbitrariness we
would allow
first we will start with a specific tool
designed to create the base of our city
the silly layout tool or how to
procedurally generate an american city
pattern it would only require two main
inputs to start
a basic shape and the path of the main
arteries
with few attributes and options
available to adjust the world network
setup it would give you an american
silly layout
the rest is figured out by the tool
with only few spline inputs it tries to
procedurally recreate an american city
pattern
we rely on the fine shortest paths who
didn't know to create the arteries
and at least the tool is calculating the
best fitting grid pattern to match to
the size defined by the user inputs
the tool can procedurally create an
infinite solution of different cities
the next step is the city zoning we have
used this extra utility to define zones
with specific attributes like a
commercial or residential zone but
mainly to shape the cityscape in a way
this becomes the vertical modeling tool
of our city we have used hoodini engine
plugin inside an arena to be able to
design the cd directly in engine
although the tool could also be used
directly in houdini for the rest of the
procedural generation
this was a user-friendly way to model
the cityscape and we made a lot of back
and forth with the art director and the
cinematic department to shape it the way
we wanted
once we are done with the basically
layout the tool is outputting a big soup
of metadata that would be used by
downstream tools to produce the city
that will include a road network the
lots definition and the sidewalk network
among many other attributes we could
also find in there
the road connectivity
the traffic density
or the pedestrian density
with this soup of metadata ready we can
now fit the ct processor and start the
final creation process
this dependency graph shows an overview
of the key components of the ct tools
and their dependencies from top to
bottom this is important because in the
procedural flow it shows where we will
need to regenerate the city in the case
we were to change a role at a given
point the dependency graph is broken up
into three stages the city base the city
core and the set dressing
and this is an overview of what the
graph would look like inside houdini
with all the actual visible dependencies
the first step in the creation of the
city is to well define the roads and
their geometries
in order to do that we take the road
network provided by the city layout tool
it is composed with spline made out of
two points it has a three layer road
hierarchy that carries all the metadata
type needs
like the road width the road ids number
of branches per intersection etc
we then trim each road section by a
carefully calculated amount based on the
angle at which the road connects and
leave enough room for the intersections
each road section would then be filled
with the adequate number of road modules
for each width we have three available
modules 20 meters 10 meters and 5 meters
subsection this way the entire road
geometry is mainly made out of 9 basic
bricks
because the sections can technically
have any possible length we keep some
room for a little bit of scaling on the
smallest 5 meter module
for the intersections we are filling up
the leftover room with road modules
scaled to the appropriate lengths we
then set their pivot at the intersection
center while they aim outward toward the
road sections
once properly calculated and assembled
the road modules are replaced by their
higher resolution counterpart this
represents the geometry as it would
appear in unreal
and the road processor would then output
a point cloud that would be used to
instance the module inside unreal using
our role processor pipeline
the role module would have two sets of
uv plus a relative vertex position
stored as vertex colors for maximum
control with the shading
it would feature
some tapered skirt on the side to ensure
smooth connection between them and would
also have a bit of curvature to add a
bit of realism to the world
once the road network and precise road
footprint is established we can move on
to the extraction of the traffic
information using the metadata of the
roads we would trace splines for each
lens and interconnect them to create the
traffic base grid
we can briefly mention here that this
network of splines contain all the
information about the traffic and would
later be imported to unreal via point
cloud
it would then be interpreted by the
traffic tools to be turned to a zone
graph
julian archon will cover more in detail
this topic later in the presentation in
the section bringing life to the city
next in our seed generation process
would come the freeway generation
for the series freeway we knew that the
chase sequence would happen at least in
part on it this had an influence on the
organic and tentacular look of it we
were after an iconic landmark easily
recognizable in the city with complexity
and pillars for the cool cinematic
parallax effects
around the needs of the cinematic
department that we are mostly focused
around the big exchanger we have built
the rest of the freeway path it is
composed of two closed loops one
overhang passage and 55 access ramps
over 25 kilometer of usable freeway
to iterate quickly our designers needed
a way to edit the freeway and find what
would work best for the chase sequence
an houdini asset was due in unreal and
would take an input curve to generate a
simple three-way deck geometry allowing
designers to create a good path for the
chase
there was a lot of back and forth
between the designers and procedural
team to make sure the freeway's shape
would serve the demo well both in
looking function
once the shape of the freeway was left
in place the designers input skiers were
brought from unreal to houdini and
embedded into the cd graph keeping the
freeway generation as part of the main
cd process
because of its organic nature the deck
had to be procedurally generated as a
mega mesh this is one case in the city
where we couldn't entirely rely on
module instancing and we had to create
custom pieces that would fit a specific
area
the mega mesh would later be divided in
small chunks of 100 meter size so it can
fit the open wheel streaming workflow
and help lumen for performances
all the others addressing pieces the
barriers pillars signs and debris are
nanite instances scattered along the
freeway path
finally as for the road processing tool
the three-way tool would output several
point cloud to be instanced over inside
the unreal and would provide metadata to
the rest of the graph it would output
several sets of meshes including the
freeway deck and its collision proxy
with the road and the freeway generated
we can now move on to the lost
processing and the building volumes
generation
for the luts we start from the basic
lots definition provided by the silly
layout tool
remember that it also carried the height
information defined by the cityscaping
we had done earlier on
we first need to ensure that we won't
rise buildings where the freeway is so
we remove it
after several layers of geometry
cleaning and filtering we are
subdivining the lots the subdivision is
using an algorithm that ponders building
height versus available surface the more
the surface the larger the final
footprint can be but only that is to
support a tall building
of course we introduce a little bit of
random in that process to not make it
look totally linear
the lowest building height are
automatically divided into new york
style lots with the typical staggered
style subdivision
as the subdivision is done you can
notice in red all the lots that have
been filtered as non-suitable for
building either by their shapes or their
topology
this is where we have introduced a
system to ensure we would cut down on
producing arbitrary data and try to
quantify the world a bit more
introducing
the building dna
each building of the city would be
described by a custom dna the dna starts
with the footprint we have created 17 of
those and any building in the city would
have one of this shape as a base so we
would always know what to expect
once the footprint is established we
added few attributes to complete the dna
the size in x and y its position and
orientation in space a height of
extrusion divided into three layers and
as an extra bit of variation mostly for
taller structures we also added the
possibility for any building to be
either cubified or with staggered floors
like the empire state building as the
last trend of the dna we would assign a
specific building style with this
technique we could create an infinite
variation of buildings ensuring every
single one of them would be unique
we can now replace non-suitable parcels
with our collection of footprints and
ensure they would fit the original space
available
for the rest of the subdivision we
simply replace them with our available
footprints it works in two stages first
we adjust how much percentage of a given
food we would like to see in the city we
then ensure it would be compliant with
this given building style this is
important because each building style
has a limit on how it can be built a
minimum wall length under which the
building generator will not be able to
fit the module that compose it
more on this will be described in the
procedural building topic later on the
presentation by robert osborne
the final part is the creation of the
building volumes themselves
populating the rest of the needed dna
strands with some global controls we
would add a little bit of extra noise to
adjust the overall feeling of it we
could finally choose how much of a
cubified or staggered building we would
want to see
so before robert covers the procedural
building more in details we will go over
the rest of the city graph and in our
next step we will look at the creation
of the ground
the ground would be under high scrutiny
since it's where the player would spend
most of its time we needed here more
than ever a very high fidelity in the
asset and thus the needs to use
instancing elegantly this represents our
collection of sidewalk and floor module
we didn't have availability for
displacement directly in engine but
there wasn't a problem
since now not remove all triangle limit
we end up pre-displacing the floor tiles
using modified mega scan surfaces with
their displacement maps each tile could
count up to 500 000 triangle this gives
you a level of crispiness and fidelity
that we could have never achieved
otherwise
so now as the city layout tour has
provided us with the network of spline
for the sidewalk and the lots definition
we could take those meshes
and have the sidewall processor within
the cd graph ingested to scatter our
module collection adaptively
dividing each sidewalk section in a
similar fashion to the road modules it
would fit the correct number of tires
solve the corners and the ground
coverage area
and here we can see how the sidewalk
processor works at different size
connection angle
it would calculate how many tiles needed
to make the sidewalks randomly assign
types and solve the external and
internal corners independently
notice how for the inside corner the two
triangles pieces scale no uniformly back
and forth to adapt
for the ground itself we would subtract
the building coverage to save a bit of
surface
and then cover it with a point cloud
where the density would be adjusted to
its ground tile size if you recall the
500 000 triangles pre-displaced piece
shown before
here you can see how many times we would
use it over the city ground 2.5 million
times that is yeah that is 1.25 trillion
triangles for the ground itself we
wanted things to look sharp and good
and that shows the same point of view
inside the engine with on the right the
different instances that compose the
ground
a little close up shows you the final
result more in details this is a good
representation of what the procedural
teamwork was on the matrix awakening
experience a giant puzzle solving with
instances
now that we have our ground covered we
can move on to the set dressing of it
first we would harvest and filter all
the areas that are left untouched
basically where there are no sidewalks
or no buildings
we have defined three main leftover zone
types to describe the city
the plaza type
the freeway type
and the parking type
to populate those areas we would use our
instance packed blueprint workflow also
shortening biomes those are
pre-assembled packages of assets
and this workflow is described more in
depth in the presentation from virtually
by creating a world that i invite you to
watch
to distribute those biomes among the
leftover areas we have used the
scattered technique using the ue space
of the zone with the uv layout node of
houdini this is a very convenient way to
let it scatter object while ensuring
that they would not overlap with each
other
for the use of the cd graph we had
developed our own version of this tool
and called it the packing scatter
it would take each dependent zone
measure its longest edge and take it as
orientation reference you would then try
to best fit the biomes together with the
possibility to choose between different
patterns and angles
we have used this tool little all over
the graph to procedurally populate areas
in an organized fashion that also
includes some of the rooftop for the
buildings this shows you a fun example
of what the packing scatterer can do to
cover any type of area with organized
pattern without any fear of overlapping
instances the last images are showing
the result of playing with different
options and inputs on the tool
and now we come to the road decals in
the ground coloring process we are
taking the traffic and parking lengths
calculated after the roads and parked
them with points for the different types
of decals over each calculated points we
would spawn a simple plane that would
feature a detailed material each marking
that you see here is an instance plane
that is carefully placed at the exact
ground level it has a detailed material
with opacity for finer details the wire
frame view gives a better idea of what's
behind the scene
if you remember during my description of
the road processor i mentioned that the
road isn't flat that actually proved
itself to be a bit of a challenge
for bigger chunks like the crosswalks or
the tire marks the plane would need more
subdivision to adapt to the road
topology
this is why we have used here a
different approach the curvature of the
road makes it a totally arbitrary object
and this was one of the case where we
had to use omega mesh
so here the bigger planes were
projecting on the road geometry to match
the topology and then assemble to a
bigger mesh
another interesting challenge with the
details were the solving of complex
intersections
a procedural graph would analyze and
interpret the lane system to create
believable markings draw roles and
basically add life to it
so now that we have produced a full
procedural cd we have control over every
single bit of information
so we can easily extract it and provide
it to the other department so they can
work their magic
to provide this data we would cover the
final city result surface with a 3
meters density point cloud on which we
will store the metadata
and by using a proxy geometry of the cd
we would use its own ambient occlusion
and indicates to the audio team at any
given point the amount of reverb it can
expect
or tell them what type of sound it
should produce
so that now we had a good overview of
the city generation process let's have a
glimpse of what the houdini graph is
actually like this isn't all of it but
it gives you an idea this graph would
take about 25 minutes to produce a
totally new 4x5 kilometer cd with its 8
millions instances meaning that in 25
minutes you could have a new cd solution
entirely different from the previous one
as a final look at the silly generator
tool this is an accelerated
demonstration of all what we have
covered in this presentation
this is a one minute speed run for a
small city example that demonstrates how
you can generate a world all the way to
have it as a playable experience in
unreal
it shows how the generator enables you
to produce a new city from the very
first curve input to the road network
tweaking the vertical shaping fine
tuning of its building to its final
generation with the raw processor
in this last part you can actually see
the raw processor in action for the
generation in unreal although this topic
is covered more in detail in the
presentation by virtually by creating a
world
you can actually try it now by yourself
as we are providing you with houdini
files and basic unreal templates to play
with
so some fun statistics to look at and
among those one that is very interesting
to mention and that represents well how
the cd processor would work
over the course of the project we have
regenerated the city 53 times for every
generation we would scout the city and
look for what we can improve in the
procedural rules
fix bugs add details to it
and finally regenerate the city at least
in parts or sometimes globally that
process including the importing unreal
with the raw processor workflow was
possible in a couple of hours for the
final version
meaning that technically we could have
had an entirely new city to discover
several times a day if we were to change
it
let me now introduce robert osborne that
will present more in detail the process
behind the building generation
i'm robert osborne a senior technical
artist at epic games
i'm going to talk about the building
generation in the matrix awakens demo
let's talk about the procedural building
generation in the matrix awakens demo
in the prototyping phase we wanted to
keep workflows as simple as possible one
dcc straight into the unreal engine
houdini and houdini engine are obvious
choices for prototyping procedural ideas
and workflows
iteration speed is king when you want to
evaluate concepts we did a lot of
prototyping and iterating a great
example of this ethos is the building
module template generates quickly
allowing building module proxies to be
created on demand to specific sizes
a building shape grammar system was
needed to make the building generation
as agnostic as possible avoiding
hard-coded behaviors that would
constantly need to be reworked and
debugged this is what i started with wow
looking back i'm having a hard time
understanding it myself luckily we were
still prototyping and iterated on the
shape grammar look and feel
here the building generator is being
used in unreal to add an extra building
to the small city level
let's reposition the building to fit on
the pier properly and change its
dimensions
now i'm changing the prop placement
density and seed
let's lower the height of the building
finally i'm changing the style of the
building and making it wider there done
building added
as we entered production we had a good
idea of how the citygraph data would
drive the building generation
json was chosen as the format for the
building definition files during
prototyping an automated pdf pipeline
was implemented in time for production
giving human readable data that could be
edited quickly to validate and debug
with the data fed to the building
generator consisted of volumes with a
bdf tag assigned per primitive face
here each color on the volumes
represents a different building style
here we can see how the data flows
inside the building generator in order
of operation till final output output
was in the form of point clouds and roof
geometry passed into the city graph or
directly into the unreal engine using
houdini engine
input volumes were cleaned carefully to
give the best chance for cleanly sliced
floor primitives to be generated in a
consistent and ordered manner
the assigned building definition file
tag allows the floor intervals to be
calculated from the bdf's level
dictionary and the volume is sliced
accordingly
once we have the floor slices corner
types are calculated using the dot
product between the primitives and
walking around the floor primitive ids
in ascending order split corners are
recognized using a co-linear tolerance
to distinguish if adjacent floor
primitives should be considered in line
corner caps when defined in the bdf are
prioritized over a split corner type
we wanted a flexible shape grammar
syntax for defining the module placement
behaviors on building facades allowing
for rapid end user iteration without
having to publish updates to the
building generator
this is a typical shape grammar the
vertical bars represent a module bucket
used to define module placement
behaviors the alphabet characters
represent a dictionary key to look up
the module metadata like width and
height
circular brackets are used to define an
infinitely repeatable macro pattern of
modules
square brackets are used to define a
fixed repeat of macro pattern modules
the asterisk character specifies that
all modules in a bucket can be scaled to
fit the shape grammar to the length of
the facade
selecting the most appropriate grammar
for a facade is driven by the total
length of one full iteration of the
shape grammar the shape grammar with the
smallest fit gap not greater or equal to
the facade length is selected here we
can see how different grammars are used
as the length of the facade increases
with the most suitable shape premise
selected the modules are placed on the
facade
here we see the module placement and
scaling according to the grammar being
used as the facade length increases
buildings are generated independently of
neighboring buildings in each building
lot this gives better parallelization
for the graph execution occluded modules
on connected building walls need to be
removed from memory and generation
performance
in this city graph each lot of buildings
are passed in as one job we take the
full lot of buildings minus the building
having its modules included and merge
and clean them the building being
occluded is booleaned against the rest
of the lot creating a boolean shell that
represents touching wall heights
additional sample points for each module
derived from the module bounds are added
for performing intersection testing
these sample points and the module pivot
point are raycast against the
intersection shell only modules where
all sample points are deemed to be
touching the intersection shell are
flagged for removal as corners wrap
around facades extra sample points are
added for corners the occlusion has to
be conservative as re-adding modules to
cover holes is complicated when you
consider primitive data for windows and
props even with this conservatism a 25
reduction in building modules props and
decals is achieved
the conservative approach is shown by
the columns of corners still present
inside some of the building shelves we
needed to indicate to the city graph
sidewalk furniture placement system
where building entrances existed the
place modules on buildings carry tags to
define functionality such as corner wall
entrance etc these tags allowed the
building generator to provide volumetric
data to simulate exclusion of street
furniture in front of building entrances
once in production new feature requests
were added to the building generator one
being multiple bdf support on a single
building volume others being window
treatments and window signage it
highlighted the need to have a
production version and a development
version of the building generator while
new features could be iterated on in a
development version without blocking the
city graph or end users using the
production version
building prop brandings were assigned
per facade across the city with just a
simple modulo seeding using the lot id
and building id for determinism
being able to have the building
generator run directly in unreal using
houdini engine allowed end users to play
with prop densities and adjust seeding
controls were exposed on the ui for this
purpose allowing prop meta to be tuned
and then exported into bdfs
here we have the building generator
running in the unreal engine via houdini
engine on this building i want to place
fire escapes on it interactively using
the volume overrides functionality the
volumes are given their override
functionality by adding active tag
strings for example the word fire escape
is used for placing fire escapes the
override volumes are passed to the
building generator using the exposed tag
volumes input let's change the prop
branding and extend the red coffee shop
props to continue into the recessed
courtyard area again using a volume with
an actor tag to represent the desired
branding on the props
for the window cube map primitive data
we wanted to create believable
functional rooms we built a connectivity
array along each facade of modules that
have a window tag with this we can
determine the maximum size of a room
that can be placed after placing a room
all instances in the room get a room id
and we move to the next window module
without an assigned room this continues
until the facade is full of assigned
rooms
a vex dictionary holds several seating
arrays to select rooms based on the
building function
in the movie you can see lights being
switched on per floor id
then by room id on each floor
and finally by room size
for window treatments window helper
objects were added to level 1 modules to
define the surfaces of the windows if
present on a module
this data was stored in the prop anchor
points for each module using the helper
category
we needed a subsystem to populate
windows signage we knew where each
building entrance was and only place
signage close to entrances using the
window helpers
the windows signage data is exported in
a building definition file for use with
the window composite system
composite layouts were selected by the
assigned facade branding the prop
placement vex code with different
filtering was used to place the
composite layouts in place of a normal
window frosting instance which would be
removed during a signage pass an
internal vex dictionary was used to
encapsulate placement rules brand
groupings and functionality with certain
masking used for building styles
all the roof geometry was derived from
the input building volumes building a
one stop recreate all roof geometry from
the floor slice primitives was too
complicated and edge cases popped up
with every tweak
uv generation and scaling controls were
added to deal with unique roofs which
could not be instantiated the uv
controls were exposed on the building
generator ui for end users to evaluate
good default values
building volumes developed from simple
cubes to complex cubified volumes split
roof support was added to deal with the
complex volumes as best as possible
not all building modules were created
equal the biggest issue being some
modules got sliced at the lower window
edge which is recessed
back from the common facade plane
we had to create a function to analyze
the floor slices at split roof edges and
apply a push or pull inset to hide these
gaps
the building generator needed to be
scalable due to the sheer amount of data
it was generating
almost 7000 buildings with props module
occlusion window treatments window cube
maps ground decals and roof geometry
this all generates in 30 minutes using
pdg on a single x 3990 threadripper pc
some data sets from the large city
generation
as we entered the end phase of the
project the building generator graph
looked like this
the volume curator passed just before
the building generator allowed the
generation of override volumes to place
fire escapes a masking scheme was used
to populate fire escapes only on certain
building groups and styles it also
allowed directed prop placement via
primitive groups
example no props were placed in the
brooklyn style courtyards multi-bdf
volumes were given steps to hide
transitions of the building styles
multi-bdf style combinations were also
tweaked following art direction concerns
the volume curator also allowed for
optimizations laid in the project memory
was a concern so the global height of
the cityscape was reduced in certain
height ranges allowing a surgical strike
without potentially causing a butterfly
effect had this change been further
upstream in the city graph the volume
curator was also used to target specific
problematic building volumes and
associated metadata
so while not directly involved in the
building generator i wanted to mention a
workflow we started using for
referencing viewpoints in the city
as the city density grew the ability to
communicate points of interest in the
city with accuracy became all too
apparent we started to use the unreal
editor command line bugit
to snapshot points of interest for quick
sharing tagging in channels with a
screenshot and a bug it go string till
we reach the pinnacle and jiras contain
burgerco information with all these data
points for pois starting to mask the
bugitco hga happened one afternoon
allowing reference points to be
available in houdini datasets to observe
behaviors and debug with pasting a
bugaco string into the bugico hda will
generate an indicator in houdini world
space
we have a reference in houdini world
space that can be jumped too quickly
using frame selected
this easily allows associated input
metadata to be explored debugged and
edge cases solved
you can round trip this data passing a
bug it go location that is derived from
the currently active houdini 3d scene
view back to the clipboard
pasting the clipboard back into the
unreal editor command line gives a super
quick back and forth for cataloging and
exploring the city data set for bugs
this is especially efficient to get the
location of an educated generation to
examine the metadata and step through
your graph and debug with allowing the
problem buildings to be isolated in the
houdini scene iterate on the fix test
locally and publish the fix super useful
for smoke testing known results after an
update to the building generator
with the sheer number of building
volumes we were struggling to identify
issues in the vast sprawling city we
were building
we literally could not see the buildings
for the city in some situations
while we had buget and bug it go to
teleport around the city and investigate
issues we really needed a structured way
to sign off on all the building styles
and building features without the
distraction of the beautiful city a
volume filter hda was created to give
targeted collections of volumes to feed
into the building generator
houdini is great chain your meta
filtering into generation then add some
automated output now you are slicing and
dicing the data to create sets of maps
in the editor to systemically close the
project
not carrying the full weight of the city
during smoke testing increased the
iteration speed greatly
special thanks to some of the quality
people i was lucky enough to work with
on this project
and now let's talk about wave function
collapse
wave function collapse is a term from
quantum mechanics in which a wave
function in superposition collapses to a
single eigenstate this concept has been
applied to game development in the form
of a constraint satisfaction algorithm
it can have
many applications including texture and
model synthesis map generation and
gameplay in a constrained satisfaction
problem a constraint is a rule that the
system must satisfy when solving here we
have a cat in a two tile grid
constructed from two options the tail
and the head there are two constraints
here the head can be to the right of the
tail the tail can be to the left of the
head it is simpler to always consider
these constraints in pairs
here we increased the grid to four tiles
and added a third option the body
we can see a total of six constraints
next we introduce a special option the
empty option
empty options are useful when you want
to ensure that the bounds of the grid
will not form open ended solves like
having a body option at either end of
the grid
empty options can be adjacent to each
other if you have an a to empty pair and
an empty to b pair then an a to b pair
can be made let's see what it looks like
to collapse a 1d grid we initialize a
six star grid where each tile represents
all of the options allowed the number
above represents remaining number of
options for a given tile
let's make an assumption that the tiles
are surrounded by hidden empty options
and both ends of the grid must be
modified to only allow options that can
be adjacent to an empty option
you can see that the number of remaining
options has dropped from 4 to 2. this
number will also represent the value of
entropy for a given tile
we now begin a recursive cycle of
observing and propagating in the
observation phase a random minimum
entropy tile is selected a selection is
randomly made from the remaining options
the tail option was chosen and remaining
options on the tile has dropped to 1. in
the propagation phase all the tiles
adjacent to the observed tile must
adjust their domain to satisfy the
constraints the propagation continues
recursively until no more tiles are
modified with every iteration more tiles
are collapsed down to a single option
the solve keeps iterating
finally the solve reaches a state where
the grid contains only collapsed tiles
here we can see this process in two
dimensions using a six by six grid
here we see the process in three
dimensions using a three by three by
three grid
a wave function collapse model is a data
asset that stores constraints a
constraint is stored in the form of a
key option an adjacency
and the adjacent option
defining constraints can be difficult
some implementations have used
label-based systems but that can be
confusing or complicated from an
artist's perspective
our implementation derives constraints
from arbitrary layouts
by doing so wave function collapse
models can be built visually and it may
help in discovering new options that are
required
you can simply specify a resolution of a
grid to solve
there is also an option to use a grid
actor which is a blueprint that visually
shows the bounding box of the grid one
advantage with the grid actor is that it
can derive starter options based on
static mesh actors that sit within the
grid on the left you can see a few tiles
pre-placed inside the grid actor and the
two different outputs on the right
it is a great way to combine art
direction with proceduralism
the city had so much complexity at
street level but once you went into
drone mode it became obvious that more
complexity was needed from the bird's
eye view
in total there were over 2 600 unique
rooftop structures made
the wave function collapse model
contained just over 5000 constraints
all of this with only 33 tileable
measures
solving these structures one by one was
not scalable so we created a solution
that can derive grids from point cloud
data
we created editor utility widgets that
can do some post solve processing here
we are swapping more materials roof
materials and per act a custom primitive
data to create color variation
we can derive a grid from a solved actor
and allow for arbitrary logic based
around tile neighbor rules in this case
we use neighbor rules to place props on
walls to reuse existing houdini methods
made for scattering props we made a
method for exporting roof only surfaces
roof prop scattering was done in houdini
and reassembled in unreal engine using
point cloud data
and here are some wave function collapse
results in the city
the wave function collapse plugin was
created by joji saruga a senior
technical artist on the special project
team
it will be available as an experimental
plugin in unreal engine 5
and we are excited to see what the
unreal engine community will create with
it
and now
here is julienne
hi
my name is julia marcia and i am an
engineering director at epic games
thanks for joining me today and see
other crowd and traffic teams unpowered
by the unreal engine new ai technologies
brought life to the city for the matrix
awakens demo
having procedurally generated the static
content of the city the remaining
challenge was to immerse the player by
making the city truly feel alive
to us it meant two things we could not
compromise on the density and we had to
ground the persistencies of this element
inside the world filling the world with
a vast amount of interactable autonomous
agents became obvious and in this case
the crowd in the traffic system became
the natural choice for a city
to meet those requirements we had to
leverage a new technology called mass ai
before moving on let's take a step back
and have an overview of the mass
framework a data-oriented design for
unreal engine of which mass ai is a
specific use case
the mass framework comes in three
separated plug-in mass entity mass
gameplay and mass ai which have a
feature set built on top of the previous
one these are all coming experimental
for the unreal engine 5.0 release
let's start with mass entity which holds
the data-oriented framework fundamentals
to better understand it let's compare it
with a classic object-oriented model in
this case the actor component model for
unreal engine
this model allows for a very flexible
way of composing the logic of the
entities in this case actors that we
want to bring into the world this model
has been a staple for video games
development for many years
however the flexibility of this model
leads to code and data in coherency due
to them being updated sequentially
also the way the actors are composed
does not guarantee that their components
are aligned in memory their access is
almost guaranteed to lead to cache
misses which are expensive for the cpu
moreover components can sometimes become
bloated and part of them may not be
required for a particular actor
on the other end
the mass remote for unreal engine
proposes an alternative way of storing
our data and decouples it from the
processing logic
we have fragments that are very small
data structures and entities which
simply holds pointers to the fragments
that represent them in memory
the fragments of entities of similar
composition are stored contiguously in
memory
and finally entities do not hold
pointers to any data so in this case any
fragment that it does not care about
as mentioned we decorate all processing
logic from the data composition itself
which is all within the fragments
to understand on which entities we want
to execute some logic we make use of an
entity query
the entity queries filters the entities
which holds pointers to the fragment
required for particular logic
processors are where the batch update
will occur and where the logic will run
for example we could be updating the
position fragment of all entities at
once by reading from their velocity
fragments but that can only occur if an
entity have both of these fragments
this segregation is what enforces data
and code currency minimize cache misses
and will trivialize concurrent execution
in the future
these are the fundamentals that are
pushing the limits on the numbers of
entities we can simulate at once
the mass gameplay part of the framework
is what allows us to tangibly bring mass
entities inside the game world
this is where we'll define our
mechanisms for spawning visualizing
loding etc
namely the entry point to bring mass
entities inside the world is the mass
spawner which is a regular actor that
you can place in your level
looking at the properties for the mass
partners
the only two things you should really
care about are what to spawn and
where to spawn these entities
we will be answering these questions in
a moment
our purpose was to bring autonomous
agent inside the well and this is where
the mass ai plugin comes into play which
encapsulates features for navigating the
world
animation behavior etc
but more importantly let's remember that
what we wanted was to bring life to a
city so we were not shooting for just
any ai
what we ultimately wanted was a crowd
and a traffic system
and the way we built these plugins is
exactly how we envision developers to
leverage and extend on the mass
framework in the future
these plugins hold all behaviors that
are specific to these use cases
before getting into the specific of the
crowd and traffic behaviors let's link
back to the procedural data that we
leverage to answer one of the two
aforementioned mass spawner questions
where to spawn the entities
the answer to this question was the zone
graph which is another experimental
feature coming with the unreal engine
5.0 release
the zone graph is a lightweight design
driven flow for ai which for the
contracts of the matrix awakens demo
replace our need for an ai nav mesh
it is an ecosystem of point-by-point
corridor structure connected by
intersections
it also stored actionable tags that can
be either static such as identifying a
pedestrian from a traffic lane or
dynamic such as an open or closed lane
that will later be useful to dictate our
ai behaviors
in fact we leverage the zone graph to
have a density based distribution of
entities for both crowd and the traffic
whereas for the park vehicles we were
more interested in a static point cloud
distribution
the mass spawners support both of this
option along with many others when it
comes to deciding how to distribute mass
entities inside the world
for the crowd we merge the procedural
data representing the pedestrian density
along with the pedestrian lane network
to create a network of interconnected
and properly annotated sound graph for
the crowd
although r2c the annotations denote what
they are for whether they are crosswalk
sidewalk or intersection lane they'll
show all the information about the
expected density and whether they are
currently closed as you can see in red
or not
these are the lanes upon which we
generated spawn location at varying
distance based on the desired density
for the traffic we did the same thing
we merged the procedural data
representing the traffic density
along with the traffic lane network
to create our traffic zone graph network
and then generated the spawning location
for the various vehicles
note that for the traffic we had to do
that operation for both the city lanes
and the freeway lanes and then
interconnect both network
finally for the parked cars we simply
directly spawn one at every location fed
by the point cloud
and voila
having distributed our entities across
the map we now need to answer the other
mass spawner question which is what to
spawn
we are talking more than just visuals
here we need to be able to define how
these entities will behave across the
city
ms entity definition is a new asset type
that we use to easily dress the list of
fragments that are different entity used
amongst the important aspects of the
definition are of course the visual
where we want to show at which lod for
example
the lod parameters themselves are
defined there what are the cut off
distances what are the visibility and
goals we care about and what is the
maximum budget per lod
these two mechanisms work out of the box
with the mass framework and are
paramount to sporting an extra large
number of entities
this is also where we added all
necessary fragments required by the
relevant processors to simulate the mass
entities behavior and for that we took
slightly different approaches for the
crowding for the traffic
for the crowd we made use of a state
tree which is another new technology
coming experimental with the unreal
engine 5.0 release
it serves as a scalable and general
purpose state machine with an intuitive
and compact ui presented by a decision
tree structure
the entire crop behavior can be seen on
screen and it describes all the states
that a crown member could be in whether
it be wandering idling fleeing etc
the state is select by running a
top-down evaluation of the entry
conditions and run its associated
parameterized task
once completed the tree will route to
its default transition state unless a
different transition condition is met
before
another benefit of the state tree is
that it is tightly packed in memory
which blends well with the mass
framework
in this capture we see the values crowd
behaviors at play such as walking around
waiting at the intersection but we also
made the characters believable
the animation coverage proposed various
walk style and speed
smooth start and stop animation and also
manages a head look at along with the
upper body orientation independent from
the character current velocity
we also note that it reacts to its
surrounding be it the player or the
other crowd members
specifically we develop a new
force-based avoidance that handles both
dynamic and static obstacles at high
performance
the crowd members can also respond to
physical collision such as playing a
one-off animation before resuming their
behaviors
we use the animation state machine to
run on the closest crowd members in
sight but all the data it used came from
the mass animation processors that was
feeding the relevant data from the
entities fragment as mentioned
previously the macelody system is key to
handling a vast amount of entities in
this case our 35 000 crore members
by default the framework handles four
different lodis along with a significant
float point value between those levels
on the screen we can see in red ten ilod
which are full-fledged meta-human actor
with factual animation in yellow to any
media melody also full-fledged meta
human nectar with less surfacial
animation in green up to 500 low lod
which are lightweight vertex animated
meshes
the rest are not visualized if you are
interested in knowing more about how the
crowd meter human were made and now we
animated the instant static measures i
encourage you to listen to the character
tech talk
because of the mass framework we also
attain a great level of persistency no
matter the lod we were switching at or
from it allowed us to always retain the
current behavior evaluation
persist the visceral so that if you go
far and back you can find that cool
looking character again and finally
allowed for smooth animation transition
even from switching from a vertex
animated mesh to a full fledge actor
since the runtime animation data was
processed in the animation fragments
for the traffic rather than using a
state tree the behavior were all
programmatically made in mass processor
which is to say that the framework does
not constrain you to an approach over
the other
the most typical behaviors were the
follow-on lane and wait at the
intersection
to prevent vehicle bumping in each other
we relied on a queuing of vehicles along
a lane
a vehicle would know the distance to the
next vehicles to manage the speed at
which it goes when a vehicle
intersection lane closes upstream
vehicles will speed down and stop at the
end of the lane
not unlike the avoidance for the crowd
the traffic vehicles also had to manage
obstacles such as the player standing in
the way or when creating car crashes
this obstacle could supersede the next
vehicle for determining the speed to go
at if the obstacle distance was shorter
in the absence of the player we assumed
the simulation to run orderly
to switch it up and to allow the traffic
to circulate everlastingly we had to
support lane changes and lane merges
this occurred when an empty spot was
detected on a neighbor lane we would
create a ghost entity to simulate the
future presence of the vehicle on that
lane
once the transition was complete we
would then remove the vehicle reference
from the previous lane this was
particularly useful for getting in and
off the freeway
similarly to the crowd the vehicle had
their own lod parameters there are a
total of 17 000 traffic vehicles and 38
000 part but drivable vehicles on the
screen we can see inred ten ioludi fully
simulated physic vehicle actor that can
be deformed destroy and interacted with
in yellow up to hundred and fifty mega
melody there are still running physics
but with simpler suspension and all
simulated within the mass framework
in green up to 5000 low lod which are
instant static meshes following simple
curves and following position updates
the rest are not visualized for the
traffic actor spawning since it could
happen at a moment's notice we made use
of vector pulling to alleviate the cost
also note that the particle are not just
there to be pretty the player can up in
any one of them drive around abandon
them and get back to them later on
finally the last step was to make the
crowd and traffic system work together
that's where the intersection
coordinators came into play
this processor was in charge of managing
the phase for which lanes to open at
which time when was it okay for the
pedestrian to cross when could we allow
vehicle turning and when we couldn't
we had a high number of intersection
configuration which added to the
complexity
lastly to manage the flow density for
both the crowd in the traffic this is
where decisions about where to go next
were made as to prevent the downtown
populace to invent the low town for
example
in the end it was not always perfect
we were not city engineer by any mean
and that is why we had to iterate on the
city and density a lot
wu thought that combining a super high
density with a persisted simulation and
adding a stop light at the end of a
freeway was a good idea but it did
create some nice anecdotes
to conclude to bring life to any world
it is true that having identity is a
great foundation and the mass framework
help achieve that easily even if there
exist tricks to fake it who is to say
perhaps nothing exists outside of the
current view you are seeing
however if density is great
persistency is king
it really helps immerse the player
inside the world and we hope that this
cut will speak for itself
you can note the green moving square to
be the traffic vehicles
the blue one to be the park vehicles and
the little white ones are the crop
members on the sidewalk
this is the result we ended up with
starting small leveraging the generated
procedural data all the way to
simulating upwards of
000 mass entities at once through the
crowd in the traffic system
this is how we brought life to the city
and it is a result we are very proud of
thank you for listening
hi my name is andreas and in this video
i will show you how to start creating a
smaller game from scratch in unreal
engine 5. we will use some of the latest
features but also established workflows
from previous versions
we will build a small top-down game and
import static meshes textures building
materials
importing skeletal meshes and animations
and build a small interactive system and
do a little bit of polish at the end so
let's start by creating a new project
when you open unreal engine 5 it
presents you with the new templates you
can start with so they contain new
mannequin many and quinn but in our case
we will start with a blank project and
just call that first game everything we
are building here i do in real time and
when i speed up time i will tell you
sure it's recorded in pieces to create a
better flow so you can follow i'm using
the assets from a stackobot sample
project you can download from the
marketplace
so here we are and when you have the
project open the first time you can see
this new map here which is already set
to word partition and has a pretty nice
real-time lighting setup but in our case
let's start a new map and we don't use
the existing ones but we just do a
completely empty level
before we start let's go through the new
ui here's a viewport with our scene and
here's the outliner listing all things
of our scene below are the details of
what we have selected
up here are different modes like select
landscape and foilers that we can use
later
this is the create menu with all kinds
of actors we can place and the queen
button starts your game the view modes
and show flags allow us to investigate
our scene down here is a content draw
with a folder structure of our game that
you can also open up with control space
in all editors with f10 you can toggle
the sidebar
let's bring in our first actor we could
navigate through the menu or just start
typing let's select the simple sphere
here it is even if we can't see it it's
in the outliner and also in the details
panel you see the properties when we
switch the view mode to unlit we can see
it there so let's make some light we
will use the environmental light mixer
to fastly set up some lights by creating
directional light you can now begin to
see the sphere we can directly change
the values like the intensity and with
ctrl l we can change the angle of our
light so it comes a little bit from the
front
this is real-time lighting by default in
the project settings under rendering you
can find the settings
new projects use the new global
illumination system lumen
so let's add some more an atmospheric
skylight the sky and atmosphere the new
voluminator clouds and a height fork we
also want our atmosphere light fully
real time so we check real time capture
in the skylight
the actors got all spawned at 0 0 0 in
the world and are a bit hidden
so let's line them up a bit so we have a
cleaner scene and don't lose the
overview
what we also can do is creating folders
in the outliner
and move our actors for the light setup
in there
projects can very fast get very messy
and some housekeeping from the start can
go a long way
next let's save our map
again let's keep it clean so we want to
do a new folder
calling it maps and size save our map as
valley
when we now take a look in the content
drawer you find this folder structure
now we want to bring in our first own
asset in the content drawer we will
create a new folder and call it props
that will contain our meshes materials
and textures
pressing import let me choose an asset i
want to bring into the engine sm crate
is an fpx that was created in blender
but you can use any dcc tool or get them
online like from sketchup we don't
change any defaults and we want to
create the materials after pressing
import our aesthetic mesh got added as
well as the three materials this fbx
uses
with double click we open this mesh in
an own editor
let's dock it up here on the upper left
you find some numbers about the mesh and
the details contain three material slots
this button leads to the location of the
asset let's open the material editor on
the upper left is a preview below our
details most space takes a material
graph where we find this big output node
where we can connect nodes to for
example this one is color we can change
when we hit apply we can see the result
on our mesh we can zoom in a bit to see
how the material is looking from
different angles let's go back and
improve this a bit when holding one and
doing a left click you can create a note
with one value we can connect this to
roughness of the material and the
preview is immediately updated hit apply
again to see how this glossiness looks
on the grate
let's make it more interesting by
importing textures
so we can import two textures here
grayscale grunge texture and the normal
so once this is imported we will find it
in the content drawer and can drag in
the normal and connect that to the
output pin
so when we zoom in a bit we see these
nice little bumps here on this material
which we can also witness on the crate
if we want
so let's go back and do one last touch
until this plastic is done
let's bring in the crunch texture and
instead of using a fixed value we use
this for the roughness which gives us
this look that it's a little bit touched
which is quite nice
so here we go this is our plastic
material so let's go to the next one
so next up is metal let's open up this
material and the first thing we want to
do is changing the color a little bit so
let's double click here and make that a
little bit lighter next we hold one
again and left click to create a scalar
and put that into metallic and change
that to one now we have a metal ball
so we do this again now with zero for
the roughness so we have this really
shiny thing let's take a look how that
looks like on the crate
that's nice
so again let's make this a little bit
more interesting by including some
textures we prepared so we go here and
we have a normal again and a roughness
but we will do something slightly
different this time again we drop in the
normal and connect that to the normal
output but if we take a look at that
ball it's a little bit too noisy for our
taste here
so we do right click and then we look
for something called texture coordinates
which gives us access to the uv tiling
so when we connect that to the uvs and
then changing the values to for example
five
and five
we will get something that's more
desirable that's nice so let's take a
look how that looks on our crate
it's cool
so um let's go to the roughness again
and this time we will bring in the
texture
we prepared but instead of using the rgb
channel we only use a red channel so you
can store different information on
different channels in a texture so and
this is our end result
nice
in the middle we want to do something
like carbon but a simple setup before we
do i want to show you something on the
mesh here you can check the vertex color
of your mesh we painted some cray values
onto the mesh which we can now use in
the material
let's open up the last material
and again we start with importing two
textures and again one is a normal and
one is this time one we use for the base
color let's take a look on the normal
for a second which opens a new editor
unreal identifies this as normal
automatically and sets up the values
it's needing so we have nothing to do
here which is nice let's go back to the
material and now drag both of those in
first we add the normal again not the
tiling we want
so with the text recorded note and some
very high numbers this time we will get
much closer to what we are looking for
now let's use the grayscale texture for
the base color
when we directly plug this in we can see
that we have the same tiling issue as
for the normal map
so let's just connect our texture
coordinate as well with the uvs for
these grayscale texture
nice
when we now hit apply and go to our
create we can see that this fits very
well
now let's use this vertex color i have
shown before
we do right click and search for vertex
color to get that input node when we
multiply this now with our texture
output and connect that to the base
color
we will now hit apply and go to the
crate
and see our result so here is our final
crate with the three materials we made
very quickly
let's bring in the floor by doing a
right click on the sphere go to replace
actor and select the cube up here we go
to the scaling tool and then we scale it
down on that we scale it up on x and y
now we have a floor we can use
we bring up the content drawer and drag
in the crate we just made
we can move it around and rotate it to
see it in our light setup and we can
move the camera a little bit around
we can also change the light again to
test how our material reacts to the
different light scenarios
and here we are with our first scene
done so now let's talk about logic
when we press play it seems nothing
really happening with a crate selected
we can scroll down into details and
select simulate physics when we now hit
play this creates faults to the ground
the disadvantage is that this is only
turned on on this specific actor in the
scene if we bring in another grade that
looks for the player exactly the same it
will behave differently
because for this second grade it's not
set to simulate the physics by default
this is where blueprints can come in
let's create a new folder and call that
game elements
when opening up the folder we can do a
right click to create assets we will
find a lot of different things but we
will concentrate on blueprints for now
and blueprints can be a lot of different
classes but we start with an actor
and we call that bp underscore create
when we open this up you can see the
viewport here in the middle on the right
we have the details for the components
that's selected and the upper left we
have the list of components and below we
have graphs functions and variables up
here you find the event graph for the
game logic but we ignore that for now
let's add a static mesh component which
we call create mesh we still don't see
something because we have to set our
static mesh crate in the details panel
of our added component so here we have
it
the details of this component are
identical to the one we saw in our level
including the simulate physics checkbox
we can also tweak it a bit by setting
the mass and increasing a bit the linear
and angular damping to introduce some
track to this actor
so we save this now and go back to our
level when we now bring in our blueprint
we just made also rotate it a bit and
press play you can maybe see it behaves
a bit differently
the advantage is when we bring in
another blueprint grade it has the same
default values we just introduced
and
when we change it in the blueprint all
actors in the scene will change too
now let's replace our floor with a
landscape
we can delete our floor and select the
landscape mode
this lets me create a landscape we do
not bother with the details yet and just
hit create
now we have a landscape that we can
skype paint or use landmass tools but i
don't want to cover that we can change
the brush size for example the strength
and the brush size
and the fall off for smoother or sharper
edges
i'm not a very good level designer so
let's try briefly to sculpt something
that looks like a small valley
like that i'm changing a little bit of
brush size and then just really fastly
drawing something here
when
you hold shift we can also lower an area
like for example here
and then we can use this tool to smooth
out
some of the roughness we brought in but
yeah let's keep it like that for a
second and head over making a material
for our new landscape
back in select mode we can select our
new newly made landscape and in the
details we will find the landscape
material so let's make a new material
for that we create a folder named
landscape and create a material here
which we name i'm underscore landscape
first we don't want to be have any
glossiness on our landscape so we can
search for fully rough in the material
settings and it does exactly what it
says
so now we have a rough thing so next we
want to add the landscape layer blend
node we can add two layers one
we will call send
and the other we will call grass
and when we plug this in now into the
base color
and we hold three and do a left click we
can create a vector node where we can
set the color into like a darkest yellow
tone we do it again but this time with a
dark green
and now we hook this up with the two
layers
back in our level we can edit to the
landscape so you can see it's completely
black let's fix that by going back into
the landscape mode and in the paint tab
we can find our two layers we just made
but the information needs to be stored
somewhere so we need to create a weight
blended info layer and we do that for
the sand in our landscape folder and the
same for our grass
so with this done we can select those
layers and begin to paint here
again a reminder that this part isn't
really my strengths but i will try my
best to paint in some grass
you can use the same brush settings as
for the sculpting
i think this is enough and that works
for us now
we can hide my simple drawings with some
improvements on the material so let's
import some more textures
here i have
two tileable textures one for sand and
one grayscale one for grass so
we can remove the scent color node for
now but i will keep the green
we can connect the scent
and bring in this grass
and when we hit apply and check out the
level we can see that we have sent here
and this very beautiful grass
but the tiling isn't very nice
so let's get back to the material and
fix that
this time we will use an absolute word
position node which gives us x y and z
on a given location
as we do not need that we will use a
component mask to get only two
coordinates and not three r is x and g
is y in this case now we can divide that
by a number to control the tiling
for example
256 could work
and now we plug that into the uvs
and now when i move around you can see
this is word aligned even in the editor
i really actually like that a lot so
let's copy this part and do the same for
the grass
i'm copying it because maybe we want
different values for now
so here let's try like 512.
so when we hit apply and go back to our
level then we can see the results so
let's get rid of this go to manage for
now so we don't have the brush
and here we are so um here's our
textures and the tiling is not too bad
but the grass is not what we want so
let's go back here and switch that back
to 256 for now
and now some cleanup so there's a very
nice new node in unreal engine 5 which
is called named reroute now so we call
that sand and now we can unplug that and
in the layer blend we use this as input
so that's pretty neat we can do the same
for the grass but before we do that
let's bring some color to the grass so
we can hold l and do a left click that
brings us an alpha lerp and we can use a
grayscale and the screen here
let's make a copy of that
and do a second green which we in this
case make a little bit brighter
and with this plugged in now into our
alpha lerp we can look between um those
two values with the grayscale so and
when previewing this this is what it
looks like so now again we do the named
rewrote now name that grass
and also color that green so it's a
little bit better for our overview
and now
we can
plug this into the layer so this is a
really nice way to keep your graph clean
and very often it's the small things
that can make a big difference you could
also make a material function here but
we keep it like this for now so and
here's the result on our landscape so
when we get closer this is pretty nice
and actually what we wanted so next
let's try to populate this with some
grass and some rocks first let's spawn
some real grass before we start let's
change the light direction a little bit
to get a nicer spot here in the middle
and then let's create a new folder
rename
environment
here we want to import a static mesh
from an fbx and another grayscale
texture we keep working with the
defaults for now
when we open up the grass clump mesh we
can see how it looks like
so let's make this grass material very
quickly we remove the color and drag in
our texture with the texture is black we
don't want to have it mask out the
material so for that we need to change
the blend mode from opaque to mask
now we can plug in the texture to the
opacity mask when we check out the grass
mesh now it begins to look like we want
let's bring some color back
we go back to our landscape and we steal
the setup by copy pasting this in our
grass material
and then we connect that with alpha and
the base color and if we take a look
this looks nice
so how do we get this grass into our
level we could use the foliage tools to
paint it in but there's an easier way
and we can leverage our landscape
material for that when we look for
output grass node
we can add that and we select that we
can see there's a grass type we can
attach here so we need that asset let's
create that asset we find under foliage
landscape grass type and call that f
underscore landscape grass
after opening it we can add different
grass types but one is enough for us so
here we add our grass clump and then we
bump up the density and we change the
min and max scale a little bit
and back in the landscape we can add our
grass type now
so next is a question where to spawn the
grass here is where the layer blend
comes in we know already where grass was
painted by adding the sample landscape
node and changing it to the layer name
grass we are actually done
so back in our level
we have now grass
is that cool
so next let's get really crazy with some
rocks
we want to import an fpx named flat rock
this rock has over 6 million triangles
so now we want to change our import
settings
to build nanite and then hit import
now i will speed up this video but i can
tell you that importing and creating the
data took under three minutes and it's
around 140 megabyte big in the content
folder
with this done we can drag our work into
the level
switching to nanite visualization
triangles you can see nanite in action
rendering only the amount of triangles
needed if you want to learn more about
this awesome technology check out our
other videos including the one from matt
and galen where they show you how to
convert your existing scenes using
nanite
in this material we do not want to work
with the mesh series so first let's
import another texture for the rock
which is the tileable
texture again and plug this into the
base color
and then let's see how that looks like
on the rock so not what we were looking
for so here we do the same as we did for
the material
for the landscape and use absolutely
world position mask that out and divide
this
in this case by a very very high number
and then plug that in into the to the
uvs
i think we do something like 1024 here
and let's see how that looks like so
much much better but when you look it
from the side that doesn't look really
nice it's really stretched so instead of
masking r b we using
y and z so to say so when we apply now
and go back
then we can see it's okay from the side
but now our top doesn't look nice we can
use a little trick here
so um we are looking for the vertex
normal
and here we can check again with a mask
and this time we only use b which is
that which is looking up upwards and
then with a lerp again
we can learn between two different
textures one is our rock so that's from
the side and then we have to bring
something else something else in our
case can be the sand texture we already
used so we plug this in and that will
have the same issue
like we had with the other texture so we
go to our landscape and we steal briefly
our setup here so we could make this now
a material function when we use this in
different materials but for our little
purpose this is enough to just copy
paste and here it is our little nanite
rock
so let's go back to the valley and here
here it is
and we want to add many of them so for
that we will use the foliage tool here
we can add foliage assets but we don't
have one yet so let's create one under
foliage static mesh foliage and we will
name this f underscore flat rock
after opening it we can add our static
mesh and let's change some values like
for example the set offset
um we also don't want this rock aligned
to the surface normal
and this rock is big so it should have
collision
so we set that to block all
and it also should influence the light
so after saving that we can go back in
the foliage tool and add it to our
palette
here we can change the density and the
min and max scale
we could also override other values or
don't do non-uniform scales but let's
keep it simple for now let's test how
that will look like first we try to get
a better overview of the scene
and then we select the rock to be
spawned and now we can actually begin to
draw them into the seam but that's not
enough more rocks so let's increase the
density
now that's still not enough so increase
again
and then let's begin to paint
yeah that that looks nice so let's begin
to cover the whole valley
with
rocks so that looks nice
more rocks let's let's add just a few
more rocks so
we have now a lot of nanite rocks with
six million
triangle account uh in this scene and i
think that's good
when we now change the view mode to
nanite visualization you can see a high
density of triangles but there is no
noticeable impact on my performance
so yeah that's where we are
let's let's get rid of the rock we
placed at the beginning and go back to
the crate by opening up the static mesh
because there we can check nanite and
hit apply this doesn't have much
polygons but as nana is a general
optimization we can profit from it matt
goes deeper in his video about
conversion from ue4 to ue5 as does chris
murphy in his guided tour
let's add a bit more vegetation i'm
using the assets from the nice sample
project statobot but this time we want
to migrate the trees and the fern from
this project to ours
we do so by selecting the assets we want
to right click go to asset action and
then migrate we will be presented with a
list of all asset reference that we want
all now we need to choose the content
folder to our target project and we
create here we are back and we have now
a new folder with a hierarchy from our
source project
this static mesh foliage we can now add
in our voltage tool for example the fern
we want a slightly smaller scale in this
level but we keep the density
and now we can select them and easily
paint them onto our landscape
maybe some more here
just to give it a little bit more color
and we can do the same with the trees
uh here as well we want a little bit
smaller trees
and um as with a fern we can just paint
a bit
in here and until we have some nice
trees
in our
little valley
so now with the fern and the trees this
begins to look like a very lovely scene
but now let's switch gears and begin
with the gameplay
before we start let's press play and see
what happens
so besides our crates falling to the
ground we can find some yellow colored
actors in our outliner many of them are
default actors that get automatically
spawned like for example it's game mode
or the pawn or the player controller
so
those three we want to replace with our
own in the project settings
under game modes
we find the default game mode base
which defines what car classes are
spawned also the startup maps are
defined here so let's briefly change
that to our valley and now we want to
make an own game mode an own pawn and an
own player controller
so let's create a new folder and name
that one framework
in there we want to create a new
blueprint class
we worked only with an actor before but
blueprints can made out of many
different classes
when we open up an actor in all classes
you will find that our crate is a child
of an actor
and a character is a child of a pawn
which means they inherit functionality
from their parent but we will based on
the gamemode base and name this one bp
gamemode for now
next we need a character
a character is based on a pawn and comes
with built-in functionality we will use
we will name this one bp bottom
so imagine this being the body that runs
around in our scene
but we also need a brain in unreal terms
that is the controller
we will need the player controller
but we will also look into an ai
controller later we name this simple one
bp player controller
now we have to tie all the three things
together and add it to our level when we
open up the game mode you can see it
looks like a normal actor blueprint we
could even have logic here the game
would should take care of
but we will only overwrite some default
classes here first let's add our player
controller here so instead of the
default one we want to use our bp player
controller it also spawns the default
pawn class and our bp bot is a character
that's based on the pawns or we can add
that here
so let's save that and close it
now we have to tell our game to use our
own game mode we could edit to the
specifics of this level in the world
settings
if we would have different game modes
for different maps but here we just want
to add it as a default for all maps so
we do it in the project settings and
here you can see there's a bp bot and
the character now
next we need to define where our
character should be spawned in the world
we use the player start actor the game
mode will use it automatically when it's
in the scene
this blue arrow shows us the direction
the character will be orientated when
spawned when we use the end key it will
be placed on the ground so let's find a
nice spot to start from
when we now hit play we will find
ourselves at that location with this
button we can detach from the player
controller to get back to the editor
controls while the game is even running
and when we now look in the outliner we
can find our bp bot and other blueprints
we made so now we have our basic setup
and can move to the camera
we can have the camera in many different
places like in the controller but we
will add it to the bot itself when we
open up the character and take a look in
the viewport we will find different
components like the capsule for
collision and movement
or the arrow component that shows as a
forward direction
and then there is a skeletal mesh
component that we will use later
and the character movement component
that will help us move this character
around and has a lot of values we can
tweak
let's make the capsule for not hiding in
game so we can see it when playing
when we now press play and detach we can
see the capture visibility is not great
in the video but it will serve the
purpose for now
let's stop and go back to our character
blueprint
for our little game we don't want to
look through his eyes but we want an old
camera that's looking from top down
to do that we will add a component
called spring arm
that will give us some neat options
we could rotate it or scale the arm
lengths but before we do let's attach a
camera to the spring arm
and now after that when we select the
spring arm again and change the rotation
we will see that the camera will follow
then we want to move it out a bit so we
increase our arm length
now the camera is above the character
looking down let's select the camera and
change the field of view of the camera
we do 45 degree for now to get a little
bit of an isometric look
the spring arm has some more handy
features it could check for collision to
adjust the camera but we don't want that
here so we disable that let's save and
check out how this looks in game
awesome this is actually what we are
looking for so next let's do some
movement
again there are several ways to do that
in our case we want to implement the
input the player is giving to the player
controller we made remember the
controller has a brain controlling our
body which is our butt as this is our
first real logic let's briefly talk
about this event here's a begin play and
a tick event there's actually more for
example a destroyed event this is
basically the parts every actor go
through in his lifetime begin play when
he spawned tick is updating while he's
in the world and destroyed when he's
removed but we don't need that for now
now we use print string to display some
text on screen it's one of my most used
notes first let's hook it up to begin
play and see what it does so when we
press play you will see in the upper
left corner printed hello let's do it
again in case you missed it here it is
so let's go back stop it here and then
hook this up to tick
so when we now hit play you will see
it's printed rapidly every tick for that
reason you want to be thoughtful what
you do here complex things on tick will
have an impact
but we want to move our character every
tick as this is a controller and not the
character itself we need to get access
to our character the controller knows
what it's controlling so we can use the
get control pawn so this pin is now our
pawn we can give orders to and we will
find at movement input on the character
now we hook this up to the event so
let's get called every tick for
simplification let's say this goes to
the movement component in our bot it
needs a direction so let's set the x of
the vector to 1.
hit play and witness our actor moving in
world x direction until it gets blocked
now we need to figure out in which
direction we want to go in blueprints we
have access to many things and this
includes location in the world under the
cursor you can go deeper and have
different trace channels but we keep it
for everything that's visible for now
here is the hit result and as it has
many information we can break this
struct to see what it gives us in our
case we only care for the location as we
now have our location in the world where
the cursor is we need one more and
that's where our bot is in the world we
can do get actor location on the pawn
with this both locations we can use a
vector mass function called get
direction it gives us a direction of
vector from two locations this is
exactly what we need here so the
character moves in the direction where
the cursor is when we now start the game
we will see the bot will be with the
camera attached following the cursor so
he's going left and right
and
down and up
super cool i didn't click in the
viewport when the game was running if i
would have you would have seen the
cursor disappear fortunately the player
controller manages that and we can go to
the details and check show mouse cursor
so if i now start the game and click
into the viewport the mouse keeps being
rendered and for the character following
that
as we do not want to follow the cursor
all the time we need to introduce some
player input to add input go to the
project settings
scroll down to input where we find
different bindings we can make there are
access bindings and there are action
bindings we will only work with action
bindings and you can imagine this like
digital on and off switches let's add a
binding called that toggle movement
we can click this little icon here to
press a key to bind that to our action
here i do a left mouse click so you can
see this is mapped now
back in our playercontroller we can
remove the begin play for now and now we
can look for the new event we introduced
with the binding we will find toggle
input here and add it to our graph
so this has two execution pins one is
fired when it's pressed and when and one
it's released so now we only want to
follow the cursor while we hold the
mouse button down so to do that we will
add a variable here and call that add
movement
this is a boolean but there are many
more variable types
in toggle input we want to set this
variable so when it's pressed
is fired we set this to be true and then
when we copy python attach this when
it's released we want to set this to
false
and now we only want to add movement
while this is true so we get the
variable and from here we can look for
an if or a branch node with this we can
say execute this order only when the
variable is true so we are done let's
start the game
and he is standing around and when we
press the mouse he's moving in that
direction and he stops when we release a
button so this feels quite nice and it's
the first time we have a feeling of
really controlling our little capsule
here
but just moving a capsule around is kind
of boring so let's get an animated
character in back in the character we
had the skeletal mesh component and we
want to use that instead of drawing our
capsule here so to do that let's create
a new folder and call this character
and here let's import the fbx that
contains our scheduled mesh
in the import menu you can see unreal
already identified it being a scattered
mesh and ask for a skeleton in our case
it's the first schedule measure we bring
in so we want to have import mesh
checked what we don't want for now is
automatically generate a physic asset
the rest we leave it like it is and then
we hit import
when we open up our character folder now
we can see different assets that got
created we already know about the
materials but we have a skeletal mesh
and a skeleton let's open this
the skeleton that got created from the
mesh has all the hierarchy of its bones
let's show the bones for a second
most animation assets will need to
reference one skeleton
so the second acid we have here is the
skeleton mesh you can see this as a skin
so you could have different meshes using
the same skeleton it contains data like
the material slots lod settings post
process animation properties and more
as we don't want this robot to be gray
but more colorful let's make his
materials quickly
it will not be massively different from
what we have done before but he comes
with some more textures and some extra
nice things for his face first we import
our textures it comes with a grayscale
albedo an atlas for facial expression
masks and a normal map
we start with the albedo and we just
plug this into the base color and then
when we take a look at him it's still
gray but a little bit more interesting
so now let's add color
we use a blend overlay note and then
attach this to the base color
and use the parameter here
and now let's find a nice color like for
example a bright orange
so when we look back in our characters
this is what we got
now let's take a look at a texture
so this one
here so in the texture editor
we can displace different informations
in red green and blue channels here we
save metalness in red in greenhouse
roughness and blue has an ambient
occlusion
so back in the material we can bring in
this and connect metallic
roughness and ao to different pins
so after applying that to our character
this is already a nice leap forward this
like like this pathetic look on his arms
but they have the wrong color so let's
fix this we can use a mask texture and
again a lot note
the green channel separates the orange
parts from the metal part
so one part is orange
and for the other we add another three
vector node
and change the color to a gray
when we hit apply and go back to our
character this is how it looks like
so some last touches by adding a normal
and give him some emissive parts first
we bring in our normal map
and connect that
and then we have this mask texture and
that uses the red channel for emissive
parts of the mesh
so we can multiply this and plug it into
the emissive output
and we multiply this with a color
for the color we take a very very light
blue
and if we have hit apply and go back to
our bot
we see his main body is ready so the
only thing left is now his face
so for the face we have one extra
background texture so let's bring that
in
this time we will plug this into the
emissive color
and then we will hit apply and see how
that looks like on our bot
so now let's add the eyes for that we
have an atlas here which is mainly a
texture with an alpha masking is
different expression and it's on a 4x4
grid so to select the face we want
first we want to add this texture to our
background texture so we use an add
and we can use alpha channel for that
because that's where the information is
stored
so now we can see the whole texture
added to the other
but we want to control the color so
let's multiply this with the color
and then again
let's change it to a bright light blue
and add
and plug this into the end
now we will use a flip book to
help us select what kind of face we want
from that atlas and we will use the uv
output so already with this defaults and
with this node we can see some animation
and it's shown on a two by two phase so
let's fix that we will bring in the
scalab parameter and change this to four
because this is the amount of rows and
columns we have so we can just plug this
in here and here and now it is running
through this like an animation so if you
want to animate a texture this is a nice
way but we want to set to a fixed value
so let's bring another parameter and
when we're changing that we can change
the face
but in our case we will keep the
standard one
very simple like this so hit apply and
then we are done and we have our
character with a face which we could
animate if we want
we will add him to our bot and do some
movement adjustments here in the bot on
the scheduled mesh we can add him now
so here it is but it's a bit in the
wrong location on rotation let's fix
that first we rotate him 90 degrees so
he's
facing in the forward direction of our
character logic
next let's take a look at the capsule
that's a little bit too big for him
first we change the radius to be a
little bit smaller and we can properly
reduce the height a bit
so back in the mesh we can change its
relative set location so it fits into
the capsule so now we have a capsule
that represents him a little bit better
it all depends on your needs but for all
little games this is okay so when we hit
play we have the character and it's
moving around nice but we can see some
issues most obviously he's not facing in
the direction he's moving towards
so back in the bot we can select the
movement component and here we can
search for rotation where we can find
orient rotation to movement
we can also increase his speed how fast
he's doing that so with this done
we'll face in the direction he's moving
to but
so that's the camera
we can easily change that by going back
to the spring arm and there for the
rotation we can switch from being it's
set to relative what it's attached to to
being set to vert aligned so when we now
hit play
it is looking like we want and this is
beginning to feel like a real game so
he's following the cursor and the camera
stays fixed and he follows it
animations are missing but before we do
that let's go back to the character
movement and make some changes
for example how fast the bot can
accelerate
the next thing is we also want to
increase the maximal step height
and a little bit the angle he can walk
on
we want to set his maximum speed to 400
and for now we will decrease the ground
friction and also
reduce how fast he is stopped when no
input is given
and we will do all that so he is slower
accelerating and not immediately
stopping when no input is there this may
feel a little bit like he's on slippery
underground and we could increase the
ground friction a bit but we will keep
this until we have sanimations in
first we will create a new folder naming
it animations
here we will import animations from
three different fbx files
in the import menu first we will select
our skleton we will already have in the
project we will also not import the mesh
as we also have that so now it's only
the three animations we are getting and
that gives us three animation sequences
let's open the idol which opens up this
editor
so here on the left are some asset
details like playrate and down here on
asset browser with animations for the
skeleton we have a walk
and a run
and the idle
now we need to connect this to our game
logic
and we do this by using an animation
blueprint for that the animation group
is also based on a skeleton so we pick
that from our bot here and we name it
abp bot
and when we open this up you can see
here is a preview below there's graph
functions and variables from normal
blueprint but the main thing here is the
animation graph where we play and blend
our animations and there's the event
curve for the logic we'll use in a
second
let's start extremely simple and just
drag in our idle and connect the pose
with the output pin
after hitting compile we can see the
result in this preview
now let's add this to our bp bot
after opening this up we can
go to the scheduled mesh component let's
go to the viewport to see what we are
doing and here we change the blueprint
so he's playing the idol
back in the game he's playing the idle
pose while sliding around
instead just playing one animation the
animation depends on the state he's in
so he's either standing still or he's
moving
we will use a state machine
and then we will call that locomotion
so it spits out a pose and that's
something we connect to our output pose
here let's go inside of the state
machine
it has an entry point where it starts
and we can add a state and call this
idle
and we can have another state
from that idle
and call that
walk
run
so this is the most simple state machine
we start at the beginning idle and we
can switch to the walk and the arrow in
the middle is a transition
so we also want to go back from walk to
idle
so let's go inside of the islet state
here we drop in our isle animation and
connect that
so it plays the animation when he is in
idle state and when we go back we can
also go into the run and walk and here
for now just takes a walk we can extend
this later
so now when he's in that state this is
the animation he's playing so next we
need to decide when do we go from idle
to walk and that's where the transition
rules comes in
here we can say you can enter or can't
enter the state but for doing that we
need some data which we will get from
the event graph here's an update node
it's like the ticking blueprint and
here's also a try get pawn owner node
that will give us that pawn but let's
first make a check if this currently has
a pawn so we try is valid function here
and with this now we can drag out of the
pawn and search for get velocity which
will give us the bot's velocity vector
at that given moment with another vector
mass vector length x and y we can get a
float that represents his ground speed
he's not jumping so we don't care for
the z direction
and this value we save in a variable we
call ground speed
so when we connect this now this gets
updated and we can test this by using
our b loft sprint string node
we can plug in the float and and
conversion node gets automatically added
so when we now place the game we can see
on the left side its current speed and
it's up to the maximum of 400 we set
before
so back in the animation
blueprint we can delete this now and in
the transition rule we can use this now
by getting our variable in and check if
this is bigger
than zero
so after doing that and pressing play
again
we can see
he is actually going into a walk state
but if we stop walking
he's not going back to his idol
that's because he is going from idle to
walk but the transition back is always
set to false let's fix that by getting
in the ground speed again and check if
this is smaller or equal
a number
and we can use like something around
five here
so now back in the game
you can see that when he begins to walk
his animation is played and when he
begins to stop then is he's going back
in his idle state
we can extend this now let's go into the
walk and run state because at a speed of
400 the rock will not work very well to
improve that we can use a blend space it
can be found under animations and then
blend space 1d and we base this on our
skeleton
we name it bs walk run
and when we open this up you can see an
axis here below the character and in the
details up here we can name this axis to
speed and we can also set the maximum to
400 to match our character speed we said
before
and now we can drop some animations in
like the walk and the run
depending on the input speed it will
blend between these two but how do we
know that the blending is not
feedsliding unreal engine 5 comes with a
very cool analyst feature for that we
can choose locomotion as a access
function
and the analysis needs to know the food
bones so we can look for the bones which
would be
food
left
so we put food left and then food right
and once we have done that he knows
where the planting is happening so when
we press analyze he will match the
animations to the right point on the
axis it might have been a little bit
subtitled because my initial points
weren't too bad but with this blend
space now we can drag this in
and use our ground speed to drive
the xs
so if we now hit play
you can see the character following the
mouse and blending from an idol to a
walk to run so in a very short time we
have our character running around in the
world and reacting to our input which is
pretty cool
so as the bot is ready we can do even
more with it let's drag the bot into the
scene and control him with an ai
controller because of our setup having
the player controller controlling the
bot we can also have an ai controller as
a brain for the body so back in the
blueprint window we can search for ii
and select the i controller and name it
bp underscore ai controller
when we open this up and go to the event
graph we will not add movement or use a
tick so let's delete that there is an ai
move to function in the ai controller we
can use to give him some orders so now
how and why and when do we give that
order
so let's do something simple first and
execute this function a few seconds
after the game starts we use the set
timer by event function and we set this
to like three seconds now we drag this
delegate out and type custom event
and this event we call simply
move
so now we connect the i move to function
and the last thing we need is give this
order to the pawn which we currently
controlling
so back in our map we select him and in
his details we find the i controller
class which we set to our newly made bp
ai controller
the last thing he needs is to move
around is navigation data where blocking
is etc so we go to the create menu type
nuff mesh and select enough mesh bounds
volume
when you press p you can make the enough
mesh data visible and invisible let's
now cover the whole area we want our
little robot to be able to walk in and
then scale this up a bit
this should work for now
so when we press play we can walk around
and you can see him begin to run after
around 3 seconds but he's trying to
reach 0 0 0 because that's what the
destination says by the default and we
will keep it like that and come to this
later all bots have the same color and
to avoid an identity crisis on our bots
let's change that we will use the
construction script of our bot for that
when we select our mesh we will remember
that our bot has two materials and his
body material is element zero this
material has a parameter i already
renamed to color back in the
construction script we can grab the mesh
and drag it into our graph and from
there we add a node called create
dynamic material instance
and we do this on the element 0 which is
our body material so here we can use the
instance and now set a vector parameter
with our color so the parameter name we
change to color and change the color to
blue
after hit compile we can see him
in blue in our scene
but now all bots in the scene would be
blue to change it per bot we can drag
the color out of here and promote it to
a variable and we name that color
and with this little eye icon here we
can expose this variable to be editable
per instance let's see this is also up
here and then we change it back to our
orange we had before
now we can give this little bot his own
individual color by going here in his
details panel and picking something like
i don't know something like a blue
i will settle on that for now
so we have our own controller and an eye
so let's do some more game logic first
let's bring in some more props so we go
to our props folder import and then we
import a wall a door an orb and some
meshes for pressure plate
when we import them they conveniently
use the same materials we already
created
so
that's nice
we will first start with our op
in game elements we will create a new
blueprint based on a simple actor
and call that bporb
when we open this up we can use the
content drawer to drop drag and drop our
meshes
into the scene which is automatically
creating static mesh components we can
make this root element and then on the
details panel we can go to the collision
and set this to overlap with pawns only
we will use this later
but first let's see how we can spawn
that into the world
so we go back to our playercontroller
and we want to trigger
an action depending on an input
so once again we go to the project
settings
and there to input
and we add another action mapping
we name this one
spawn op
and we press here and hit spacebar to
bind that
to that action back in the controller we
search for spawn op input event
and then
on the
release
we
use a function called spawn actor from
class
and the class we want to pick is a bprp
so with a right click and split we can
access the variables of the struct so we
need a location to spawn it we can use
the same location where the bot is in
and the moment we hit the space bar
so we add this to the location hit save
and now
we can walk around
and spawn ops
with orbs in the world we want say i now
to collect them so instead of walking to
0 0 0 we want the bot to go to an orb
and we can use an a function to find an
op and we call this function find op
this function should output if it found
the op so we do a boolean which we call
success
and we add a second one
and change the type to an actor
which we will name
op actor
so let's make the logic for that
first
we want to get all actors of class
and here we want to look for our bp
orbs
in the scene this gives us an area of
all ops it's basically a list we can use
get length of that list to check if
something is in it
so if we if this area is bigger than
zero we can use a branch and if this is
true we found something and if it's
false
we say we were an oxford not successful
and if it's true we found ops so now we
make this simple and just get the first
op in that list
and plug that into our return node
and when we hit compile and go back to
our event graph we can track in our
function
so we made our own node we could now
hook up like we did before but in this
case we can make this function a pure
and when we drag this in now it doesn't
have execution pins be aware that also
means each time a value is needed from
this node it will be executed but that's
okay for here so if we are successful we
will do the ai move to command and we
will use the op actor output and plug
that into the target actor
and then when the eye reaches the
destination successfully we want to move
again
in addition we want to change our timer
and check that this is looping so it's
checking every
three seconds when playing now we can
spawn orbs
and our little blue robert will go
and run to the orb but as the op still
will be the first in the list he will
not move to another for that we need to
remove it from the world
to do that we can use events the
components can give us for example the
begin overlap event we already know this
actor will only overlap with pawns
because that's what we said in the
details that includes our own bot and
their ibot here we get the actor that
begin to overlap with this orb
we don't want our player to directly
move it after it got spawned so we have
to differentiate between them so we cast
to a pawn
carefully with casting it has hard
references and it means when an actor
gets loaded memory everything it's
casted to will also be loaded now we
drag out the pawn and we can ask if this
is player controlled
as we have an ai and a player controller
this will give us a desired result so if
the bot is not player controlled we will
destroy and thus remove it from the
world here we are
so now let's hit play and see what it
does
we can spawn orbs and their eye now
begins to follow us
and collecting those orbs so
here we have it
running around spawning orbs and having
a little ai following us
now let's add some more interaction and
do some more game elements we will do a
pressure plate that will open a door and
we want our robot to be able to trigger
it first we create another blueprint
actor and name this one bp pressure
plate and when this is done and we open
it up we can drop in our frame and
platform mesh
and then make the frame our route
when
what we want to do is move the platform
up and down when something stands on it
to do that we will add the box collision
component that will serve us as our
trigger so let's scale this up a bit so
it covers the area we want
and now we want to add a begin overlap
event like we did before with the orb
but this time we also want the end
overlap event
and we now want to test if this is
working so we use our print string again
we keep the hello for the begin overlap
and we add another one for the end
overlap where we say
goodbye
so with this done let's go back in our
level and get into the content drawer
and just look for our elements bring in
the pressure plate
and when we press play and move around
you can see the hello and bye being
triggered when we begin and end overlap
so this is already working quite nicely
but we don't want to output some text
but move the platform mesh up and down
so back in our pressure plate
we will first remove this print string
node and to do the animation of the
pressure plate we will use a timeline
and we name this plate animation
so when we double click he we can add
different tracks to this one but first
we want to go pretty fast so we set the
length of this timeline to be half a
second and next we will add a float
track so this track we will use to
animate the plate movement now we can
add some keys so the first key is at
zero second and the value to be zero
and then we do another key and that one
will be set to 1 after half a second
and with this buttons we can focus on
that area so this value will increase
over time from 0 to 1 and we will use
this to move our plate
so here is our float pin that will give
us a value when the timeline is playing
we will take the platform mesh in here
and look for a set relative location by
start this is zero zero zero
we want to have this updated when the
timeline plays as we only want to change
the z value of this vector we will use
one of the mass nodes and search for
multiply
the pins here are grayed out because
it's wide card pins that can become
different variables they get
automatically changed when i track
something in and now we can split our
location vector and connect the output
to the set component
so when the platform reaches one we want
the plate to be at around minus 20. so
let's hook this up and the timeline and
we can do it play and reverse when end
overlay is played so now back in our
level we can run around and you can see
it's already triggered but maybe a
little bit hefty so
before we continue let's stop here go
back and fix this the value is a little
bit high so we go to -10 and i think
that should work better so let's play
again and see how that is doing
yeah that's what we want so the plate is
moving down and up
so we have the pressure plate now let's
create another actor for our door and
call this one bp door
when we open this up we do the same as
before we will go to our props folder
and first we will bring in the wall
frame and make this one's root next we
need the two door meshes
it's the same mesh for both so we will
add two of them
and let's name one
door l for left and the other one door
right
as we want them to move around here but
it would be easier if the relative
location would stay at 0 0 0. so let's
do a small trick we will add a scene
component and
we call this like anchor underscore
and we move that to the proper position
then put the door under that anchor and
bring back the relative location to zero
we do the same for the other side so we
add another scene component and call
this one anchor
underscore r
and then move this to its proper
position on the other side in this case
the door moves in the opposite direction
as the other sorry rotate this one 180
degree and now we can put our door under
the anchor and we have a setup we can
easily work with
back in our event graph let's first
delete those notes
because this time we will start with
custom events the first one we want to
do
is calling this one open door and then
we need a second one we will call
call closed door and again we will do a
timeline calling this door animation
um this is
nearly the same setup as before we will
do one tiny thing different which you
will see in a second so door animation
and then this time we will make this
also as short 0.5 seconds we could also
do vector tricks here but i personally
prefer to work here in a zero to one
space and tweak the values afterwards
with the multiplayer
without the need of changing the curve
every time so the curve we want to model
just like how how in this case the
animation is played
but first we need this first two keys
and then we can do it a little bit more
interesting by selecting those keys and
changing them from linear to break and
that gives us tangents and this tangents
here we can use to manipulate the curve
so we can bring this down to have a more
interesting
sliding and back in the graph we can
take both door components
and again look for set relative
transform we put this under the anchor
so that will help will help us a lot
again we split the vector and this time
we use a multiply again and we will
multiply it
with minus 70.
we connect it to the y component so the
door slides in and out of the frame
so open door should play time forward
and close should play it in reverse
so this is it and for a quick test we
want to see if this works so we will get
back our begin play we want to open the
door after a few seconds i normally
prefer the set time setup but we will
use a delay node
which will work for now
and then we will open the door so we can
go back to our level look at our bp door
and drag that into our level
let's try to find a nice spot like here
at the entry or exit of the valley so we
have to try to open that
um we could properly place it a little
bit nicer but i think this works for now
so evola after three seconds the door
will swing open
so how does the plate now tell the door
when to open there's a lot of ways to do
it and you can look into blueprint
communication to learn more i want to
show you one way and that is using an
own component we can create a blueprint
here and we find an actor component
let's create one and let's call this one
bp interaction component imagine this to
be a small container for game logic you
can add to any actor in your project
so when we open this up it looks like
any actor blueprint we have seen before
but it doesn't have a viewport or
components let's remove this for a
second we will do something extremely
simple here we create a custom event
that we can call from outside later
first we call start interaction and then
we do a second one and this one we will
call stop interaction
next we will use an event dispatcher
which will give us a possibility to
shout out into the world that this event
occurred and we call this one on
interaction
and up right here we can add a variable
and we keep it a bool and say simply on
now we can drag it in and call this one
from start interaction and say this is
on and then we do a second one on stop
interaction and here we say it's false
that's all com our component will need
so let's hook this up in the pressure
plate we can now add our new component
we just made
there it is
so um let's move the um overlap events a
little bit to the side and then we can
drag in our component and use it as any
other from here we can call the events
we created start interact onbegin ever
interact and then start the animation
and also stop interaction when the end
overlap is called and then place the
animation
in reverse to show this is already
working we go back and use our print
string again and saying for example
on
when the interaction starts and we do
another one and we just say off
when this happens
so with this hooked up we can test if
this is working so let's start our game
and move our character around so when we
enter the plate you see on
and off
so this is already working quite nicely
now the door needs to react on that
packing our door we can remove our test
code for opening the door and at
beginplay we want to listen to the event
dispatcher of the component that's
calling out into the world that an
interaction started or stopped first we
will add a new variable type and call
that trigger
then we change the type from a boolean
to an actor object reference because any
actor could actually have our
interaction component we can drag this
variable in and then we can check if
this is even existing so we do right
click and change this to a validate get
and now from that trigger we can
move this pin out
and search for get component by class on
that actor
so here we can check if this actor has a
bp interaction component
so again um we check if this is valid
um and when both is the case we know we
have an actor here that has our game
logic we just created
we can track out here and assign a
custom event to this event dispatcher we
called on interact so at beginplay we
assign this event to the event
dispatcher and when this is calling out
we can react on that we can now use a
branch again to decide what to do when
this is true or false so if it's true we
want to open the door and when it's
false we want to close the door
and with this we are done so let's save
and go back into our level and set the
trigger variable by selecting the door
and i forgot something so we have to go
back to the door and make the trigger
editable per instance with this eye icon
so let's compile and go back
and when we select the door now we can
use a picker to select the pressure
plate when we now start the game we can
walk onto the plate and that triggers a
door and it leaves the door and open
and close and it also means when we now
spawn our orbs and our little bots
collecting them we can make him open the
door for us so we can safely leave the
valley
even after so many years i still love
the moment when all these little
features come together oh by the way we
also can push the crate onto the
pressure plate because we didn't check
who's overlapping with it
let's do a bonus round and add a bit of
polish by adding effect sounds and a bit
of camera shape we will start with a
dust effect for the bot's running
animation and first let's make a folder
and call that effects here we create a
completely empty niagara system and we
will call this one
fx dust
so let's open the niagara editor again
we have in the middle a big graph
here are some parameters and here is a
preview we will do something extremely
simple first we want the system not to
loop but only play once next we need an
emitter we could use one of the many
templates but we'll start an empty one
this also has life cycles like an actor
but in update we add a burst
uh a spawn burst and let's add something
like 10 particles
in
particle spawn we can set some particle
values first we set the color to do
something
that could look like sand
next we want to a bit of randomization
for the size of the particle so let's
check uniform random uniform and do
something between 2 and 4. we also want
to randomize the mass a bit for the
gravity we will introduce in a second
and next we want to add some velocity
when the particle gets spawned
adding this also needs a solve forces
module which will be added when we hit
fix
instead of a linear force of all
particles we want to switch to cone and
the direction of the cone we want to set
to -1 to fit our character later so in
preview you can see now 10 yellow
particles moving in -6. we could change
the velocity speed but we'll keep it for
now there are many more things we can do
with our particles but we will keep it
simple
as this should be dust we want to scale
it up over time so in particle update we
will look for something called
scale sprite size
this gives us a curve and we want it to
be much bigger like maybe something like
15 when it's the end of his lifetime so
you can see now they are getting much
bigger now they should move a little bit
more interesting so we can add a curl
noise to get a little bit of chaos we
can increase the strength a bit
which gives us
this
so next we could also change the
frequency but we will keep it for now
um next let's add some gravity so if we
add gravity as a force
um it will they will by default fall
down with minus 980.
we do not even want a negative value so
in other like this in our case we want
to get it a positive value so that's a
that's much better maybe this is a
little bit much so like that
here is where also the mass come in that
we said earlier last thing is changing
the alpha over time so it blends out we
can use a scale color and we can change
this from the fixed number to a float
from curve
now we can drag the zero value to happen
a little bit earlier in the time
and we have particles that begin to plan
blend out the agarwa is very powerful
and i'm using only a super tiny piece
here but we need to move on and see how
we can use a dust now
to spawn that
on the footsteps we will go to our
animation and open the run animation
let's change the camera angle and stop
here
below of the camera we have different
tracks and one of them is called notify
we can scrub to where the right foot is
touching the ground where it's planted
like
here for example
right click and add notify is where we
find plane jagara particular effect
when we select this we can add our dust
effect in the details and when we now
moving on the timeline we can see it
gets spawned and played once but it's
spawned at 0 0 0 of the character and
not where the food is
we can add a bone or a socket name here
and we will pick food r for this right
food now let's get spawned where the
food bones are let's do it for the other
leg as well
we will add a notify
first we will scrap where it is so here
and then we will do right click and add
a notify
select the event and
we switch this to foot
left
now we have them spawning at the right
location at the right time
when we know go back in our level and
hit play we can see the particles
getting spawned when he's running around
so we are leaving a little trail of dust
behind us
audio can help greatly with player
feedback and is as important to a game
as all other aspects let's make some
procedural generated footsteps we will
add a new folder and call this audio for
this one we will use meta sounds which
is a plug-in you might have to enable
under plug-ins and restart your engine
which i already did here
so
we will add a new metasound source asset
which we'll find under source and call
this one
sfx footstep
when we open this up you will see a big
graph again we can compare this with a
material editor where you can play
pre-made sounds music mix it or even
generate sounds out of thin air
which i do here with a white noise
well that was loud let's control this
noise by adding an envelope there are
several ones but we want the one that
outputs audio
we multiply this result now with our
noise
and then we connect this to the output
we also connect the on done pin to the
unfinished so the sound now is when it's
ended let's hear how that sounds like
we can hear difference as this sound is
now blending in and out let's modify the
attack timer and the curves
and test again
that's close
so we can extend this now by adding a
square generator
here we set the frequency very low
and now add this to our noise with an
add node
and then we will plug this in to the
multiply with our envelope and that's
what we got
so we increase the pulse width a little
bit and the noise is very loud so we
multiply this with a float like
something 0.1
and then plug that in and this is the
result
i'm obviously not a sound expert but i
hope you can get an idea how powerful
this is so it's close enough for me back
in our run animation we can add a new
notified track so let's stop this for a
second
um now we can do a right click add
notify and then play sound when we
select this you will see that our
footstep is already selected that's
because i still had it selected in the
content draw
so and this is how it sounds like so
let's add a second notify with the other
feed place it properly
and this is our animation
when we play in game we can see and her
ears about running around
and when
we spawn some orbs
as we use the same body
you can now hear both spots running
around
making noises
isn't that lovely
as a last touch for this project let's
shake the camera a bit we go to the
effects folder and there we create a new
blueprint class this time we look under
all classes for camera shake base
we will add this and call our ones just
simply
camera shake
when we open this up we have some
properties we can change
first we pick purlin noise
and then we will tweak the amplitude and
frequency in a second but let's open
timing first we reduce the duration to
something very short
and we also decrease the time to blend
in
and out of the shake
so for example something tiny like zero
zero one and zero zero five
for the location amplitude we do an
eight and the frequency we do twelve for
now let's save that
i want to play it on the door so when
the door opens or closes we want the
earth to be shaking after selecting the
door i press ctrl b to find the asset in
the drawer in the event graph here as a
door gets moved by the timeline we can
add play world camera shake we select
our shake and we need to define where
the location of the ap center is
so to do that we want to do it where the
door is so we do get actor location
and then plug that into the epicenter we
can specify the radius this is felt by
and we increase this to a very high
number and hit save and let's see how
that looks like
when we now run around and trigger the
door
the camera shakes a pretty heavy door we
have here
that's it we made a tiny game touching a
lot of different new and established
features in unreal engine 5. we imported
the static measured textures we made
different materials we used high polygon
rocks created a character set up as
animation added an ai
and did some game logic spawning
collecting orbs and adding in the action
component to trigger a door we made some
dust we generated sound and i can
imagine this is a very good start for a
small puzzle game
we used assets from our own stikobot
sample you can download on the
marketplace a lot you learned here can
also be found in that project it's a
great place to start if you prefer
learning by tinkering if this isn't
enough for you i recommend you check out
our new starter game lyra
we hope this will help you getting
started and looking forward to see what
you will create in unreal engine 5. join
our new developer community and don't
miss the great videos my colleagues and
some of the community members already
created thanks for watching
you